Meine Damen und Herren, Sie wissen, die Verfassung, das Grundgesetz, stellt das Bekenntnis zur Unantastbarkeit der Würde jedes Menschen und den Grundrechtekatalog mit seinen Freiheits- und Menschenrechten nicht zufällig an die Spitze aller Bestimmungen der Verfassung. In die Freiheit des Menschen soll sowohl die Grundlage seiner persönlichen Entfaltung als auch seiner zwischenmenschlichen und sozialen Beziehungen sein. Aus diesem Grunde wählen die Grundrechte auch nicht nur, ich habe es schon angedeutet, nicht nur als Abwehrrechte gegen staatliche Gewalt, gegen den Staat, sondern darüber hinaus auch ganz allgemein als objektiv-rechtliche Bemühungen einer Werteordnung für alle Bereiche des menschlichen und gesellschaftlichen Lebens in der Politik.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 135. Jetzt nicht mehr aus Wien, sondern ich bin wieder zurück in meinem schönen Berlin und sitz hier brav an meinem Tischchen. Und naja, nachdem es in der letzten Zeit einen gewissen Mangel an technisch orientierten Sendungen gab, dachte ich mir, bleib ich doch einfach dabei. Und fahre auch hier weiter in gesellschaftlichen Dingen fort. Denn ich finde, es ist irgendwie an der Zeit. Es ist jetzt einfach auch derzeit, würde ich mal nicht, der Zeitpunkt, wo man die ganze Zeit nur vor seinem Computer knien sollte und über Programmiersprachen nachdenken. Das war manchmal auch ganz lustig. Aber es gibt einfach echt zu viele Sachen, über die auch mal geredet werden muss. So, und darum geht es heute. Und ihr hört schon, ich bin nicht alleine, wie das immer so ist. Aber diesmal haben sich hier gleich zwei Menschen zu mir gesellt, nämlich zu meiner Linken, der Ilija, hallo.
Hallo, grüß dich.
Ilija Trojanow. Das ist richtig ausgesprochen.
Na, ich bin dafür, dass jeder das aussprechen kann, wie er will.
Ah, das mache ich mit meinem Namen auch so. Dann spreche ich es mal so aus. Und zu meiner Rechten, Juli, Juli Zeh, hallo. Find ich super. Wir haben ja hier monatelang, glaube ich, an diesem Termin gearbeitet.
Das war nicht einfach.
Ja, war nicht einfach. Aber jetzt hat es geklappt. Das finde ich prima. Ja, vielleicht sollte ich erst mal so ein bisschen, soll ich erst mal ein bisschen nachbohren, wer ihr denn eigentlich so seid. Um es vorwegzunehmen, heute war ja großer Rommel um euch, durch euch ausgelöst, weil ihr gerade ein Buch ausgebracht habt. Da soll es ja auch so ein bisschen drum gehen, aber mehr um darum, worum es in dem Buch geht sozusagen. Also ihr seid beide Schreiberlinge, sag ich mal so. Und schon immer auch gewesen, oder? Du hast, wie ich gerade in deiner Bibliothek entdeckt habe, du hast ja einen Migrationshintergrund.
Ja, nicht wahr?
Da bin ich total neidisch drauf, dass das super Migrationshintergrund ist.
Ich habe in mühsamer Kleinarbeit deutsche Sprache gelernt. Nun, heute ich besser sprechen als alle Deutschen.
Man merkt's.
Nicht wahr? Ich vor allem an Aussprache hart arbeiten.
Das ist hervorragend. Da komme ich auch gut vorwärts.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass wir hier vorwärts kommen.
Warst du immer schon so eine Bücherratte oder?
Ja, also ich bin ja ein bisschen älter als du. Und insofern gab es damals noch keine Computer, kein Internet.
Geringt bin ich älter als ich.
Na ja, aber manchmal sind die geringen Unterschiede ziemlich wichtig. Und nein, dazu muss man auch sagen, ich habe die ersten sechs Jahre in Bulgarien gelebt. Und es war ja wirklich so, dass im Osten aufgrund der totalitären Überwachung und Kontrolle aller Lebensbereiche, dass die gebildeten Leute sich aufs Buch zurückgezogen haben. Weil das so ungefähr das einzige war, sozusagen die Bibliotheken, die man teilweise auch geerbt hat. Das einzige war, wo man noch einen ruhigen Gedanken fassen braucht. Genau, ganz genau. Und insofern bin ich schon sehr früh mit dem Buch aufgewachsen. Und nach der Flucht, wir sind dann geflohen über Italien nach Deutschland, später nach Kenia weiter, war es so, dass ich mehrfach neue Sprachen lernen musste. Und meine Eltern haben zu Recht halt immer insistiert, dass man Sprachen lernt, indem man sehr viel liest. Insofern habe ich ja, ich habe dann mit 12 Deutsch gelernt und habe dann eigentlich seitdem sehr, sehr viel gelernt. Also in der Jugendzeit, sehr viel gelesen. Also in der Jugendzeit würde ich sagen, manchmal ein Buch pro Tag im Durchschnitt.
Das heißt, das war sozusagen durchs Lernen, bist du dann auch, hast du dich sozusagen dem Buch genähert?
Genau, ich habe dann festgestellt, dass es eigentlich ziemlich geil ist und bis zum heutigen Tag finde ich, dass es keine schöne oder fast keine schöne Betätigung gibt.
Und was hast du dann so geschrieben?
Ja, ziemlich viel, wie bei Juli auch. Nein, nein, nicht nur. Also ganz viele verschiedene Sachen kann man eigentlich gar nicht auf einen Nenner bringen. Also ein paar Romane, Die Welt ist groß und Rettung lauert überall, war der erste. Das ist eine Geschichte über Flucht, über Fantasie, über Widerstand, über Spielen. Es geht auch um Backgammon-Spielen und dann gab es einen, das wird die Zuhörer vielleicht interessieren, einen Versuch, einen Internet-Roman zu schreiben.
Ein Internet-Roman?
Ja, damals hat das ZDF, das war glaube ich 1996 oder 1997, war damals alles noch ziemlich neu und dann haben wir wirklich versucht, also zum einen, dass die User dann im Netz sehen konnten, wie das ganze Ding entsteht. Zum anderen natürlich Hypertext, das heißt beliebige Links, also die Textfagmente mussten so geschrieben sein, dass sozusagen jedes zu jedem passt. Und dann haben wir auch versucht, die User irgendwie einzuladen, zum Mitschreiben und das war eine völlige Katastrophe, also völlig. Also es kamen wirklich die absurden Weirdos, kamen daher, also von irgendeinem...
Aber es gab, glaube ich, nur absurde Weirdos im Internet.
Es war immer noch so, oder? Mach den Laden endlich dicht.
Nein, aber es gibt ja kreative und sympathische und tolle Weirdos. Aber nicht im Internet. Ihr zwei kennt euch besser aus, deswegen kann ich jetzt gar nicht abonnieren.
Wie hieß denn dieses Projekt?
Das hieß Autopol. Ach so, wie das Ding hieß. Wie hieß denn das?
Dieses Internet-Pol.
Mein Ding hieß dann Autopol. Und das war eigentlich eine hochgradig politische Sache, die fast eigentlich hier zu unserem jetzigen Buch führt, weil es ging darum, also ein Art Science-Fiction-Thriller, dass die Gesellschaft irgendwann mal keinen Platz mehr hat für oppositionelle, kriminelle Atommüll und so weiter und so fort. Und diese Sachen werden dann irgendwie in die dritte Welt verschifft. Nur bis dort Platz ist, werden sie, weil es steuertechnisch und administrativ einfacher ist, werden sie auf so einer abgeschlossenen Autobahn zirkulieren, die einfach ist, bis sie irgendwann mal dann sozusagen ausländisch gebracht werden können. Und dann gibt es eine Gefangenen-Revolte, es gibt einen Stankarazin, einen aufrührerischen Anführer dort und die machen dann Aufstand und dann... Genau, und deswegen waren das ganz normale Leute und ich habe gar nicht kapiert, dass sie normal sind. Naja, dann gab es, es gab dokumentarische Bücher, ich habe mich sehr intensiv damit beschäftigt, was 1989 und danach im Bulgarien passiert ist, weil von Anfang an mich diese...
Also nach Auflösung des OZblogs.
Genau, aber diese übliche Darstellung, irgendwie wunderbare friedliche Evolution, Friede, wie heißt das? Friede, Kuchen, Eier, wie heißt das nochmal? Freude, Eier, Kuchen. Genau, Freude, Eier, Kuchen und Mohn. Oh man, wir kommen durch einander. Bei den Sprichwörtern merkt man immer den Migranten-Hintergrund, das wird man halt nie gespürt werden.
Ich habe auch Migrationshintergrund.
Du kommst aus Ulm. Du kommst aus Ulm, das ist ja noch schlimmer als aus Sofia. Ich komme nicht aus Ulm. Und ich hatte immer das Gefühl, dass da etwas ganz anderes passiert ist und ich habe das anhand des Beispiels Bulgarien wirklich jahrelang sehr, sehr genau recherchiert. Das Buch heißt die Fingierte Revolution und dann gab es Bücher über Afrika, Indien, dann wieder ein Roman, der Weltensammler. So, jetzt habe ich aber genug über mich geredet, weil die Juli, die ja eh nicht viele Bücher geschrieben hat, noch gar nicht zu Wort gekommen ist. Und dabei ist die Juli zehn Jahre jünger.
Ich wollte ja mal erstmal so ein bisschen ein Bild machen, mit wem es hier eigentlich zu tun hat. Also im Prinzip, Romane, also du schreibst halt breitbandig sozusagen.
Ich schreibe alles. Ich habe ein Opern- operettes geschrieben, Film, Drehbuch. Hauptsache schreiben. Hauptsache schreiben, genau. Ich bin da völlig emotionslos, überhaupt keine Auswahl. Einfach gib mir ein Blatt Papier oder eine Screen und wird voll gemacht.
Ja, ich bin auch so willenlos und auch ohne Auswahl. Wir sind uns sowieso total ähnlich. Das haben wir heute schon mehrfach festgestellt. Also wir haben die gleiche Mutter quasi, weil wir haben beide eine Mutter, die immer, wenn man im Fernsehen auftaucht, hinterher total sauer ist, dass man vorher nicht Bescheid gesagt hat. Deswegen mussten wir heute beide, nachdem wir irgendwie beim NDR gefilmt wurden, unsere Mütter anrufen und sagen, wann das läuft, weil wir nicht machen die totalen Terror. Also quasi aus dem selben Ei gekrochen. Aber jenseits dessen ist es bei mir auch genauso wie bei Ilija, dass ich nicht gattungsgebunden so schreibe. Also ich würde schon sagen, mir sind Romane am wichtigsten. Wenn jemand käme und sagt, du musst dich jetzt entscheiden, du darfst in Zukunft nur noch eine Sorte Text schreiben, dann würde ich auf jeden Fall sagen, dann schreibe ich nur noch Romane. Alles andere ist für mich immer so ein bisschen eine Zwischenübung, eine Nebenbaustelle oder irgendetwas, was ich halt auch mache gewesen. Und der Roman so als Form ist für mich immer die Königsgattung.
Das heißt, ihr seid eigentlich Kinder der Friktion?
Ja, total. Also da kommt das auch her. Bei mir kommt das Schreiben nicht so sehr aus dem Sprachenlernen, weil ich bin halt so eine langweilige Deutsche aus dem Westen der Republik. Ich habe auch nicht so coole Stories wie Ilija, warum ich mich für irgendwas interessiere. Also er wurde immer verfolgt und abgehört und ist geflohen. Sowas habe ich alles nicht.
Du warst einfach nur da.
Ich habe mich so saumäßig gelangweilt, dass ich mir immer total tolle Geschichten ausgedacht habe und dann angefangen habe, die aufzuschreiben, schon recht früh. Schon so mit sieben, acht. Wann hast du eigentlich angefangen zu schreiben?
Viel später.
Du konntest ja kaum sprechen. Genau, dann musste ich erst mal sprechen werden.
Aus dem bist du ja eh ein Wunderkind. Ich bin sozusagen ein Spätsünder. Also bei mir hat alles längst raus.
Voll das Wunderkind. Also ich habe früh angefangen mit Schreiben und das dann immer weiter gemacht und wir haben beide aber auch andere Sachen in unserer Ausbildung probiert. Wir sind zum Beispiel noch eine Gemeinsamkeit. Der Ilija hat auch mal Jura studiert. Ich habe auch Jura studiert. Er hat abgebrochen, ich nicht.
Das könnte ja dann schon mal ein Grund gewesen sein, dass ihr jetzt ein gemeinsames Buch geschrieben habt. Heute gab es auch eine tolle Pressekonferenz dazu und habt irgendwie ein bisschen berichtet, wie das so überhaupt kam. Kann man vielleicht noch mal wiederholen. Wo war das? In China wart ihr?
Ja, es gibt so Autorenverschickungen, Programme, da werden deutsche Autoren woanders hingebracht. Warum genau?
Am deutschen Wort, die deutschen Kulturen zu bewerben.
Am deutschen Wort soll die Welt sich laben.
Das ist also Goethe-Institut oder was?
Ja, schon ziemlich.
Aber China ist cool, das ist die beste Reise, die man machen kann, weil die Chinesen alles völlig durchorganisiert haben. Das heißt, bei gemeinsamen Treffen steht eine nach dem anderen auf und beginnt eine der Autoren zu loben und am Ende der Veranstaltung haben wir festgestellt, dass jeder, es waren vier Autoren, dass jeder Autor genau von jeweils zwei Professoren genau jeweils zehn Minuten mit ähnlichen Worten gelobt wurde. Das heißt, die Lobhutelagen.
Und bei uns erhobt sich dann so eine halbe und sagte, ja wir finden euch auch total super und setzte sich wieder. Also ein gewisses Missverhältnis.
Oder die andere super Sache beim Abendessen hat der Ingo Schulze einen Witz losgelassen, den ich jetzt nicht gerade genial finde, aber so ein alten Witz. Honecker und Mao Zedong. Und dann fragt irgendwie, dann fragt Mao Zedong, Honecker, wie viele Dissidenten, Moment, nee, Honecker fragt Mao Zedong, wie viele Dissidenten habt ihr eigentlich? Und Mao Zedong sagt, naja, es werden so ungefähr 16 Millionen sein. Dann sagt der Honecker, genauso wie viele wie bei uns. Das Verrückte war, an dem Tisch hat genau die Hälfte des Tisches, also die Chinesen am Tisch, genau die Hälfte hat brüllend gelacht, als ob es das lustigste ist, was sie jemals gehört haben. Die andere Hälfte hat überhaupt nicht mal den Mund verzogen, also völlig starre Gesichter.
Das heißt, die haben da auch ihre Jubelchinesen sozusagen auch genau abgezählt im Vorfeld.
Das sind die, die sowieso schon mit einem Bein im Arbeitslager stehen, die können dann auch noch über solche Witze lachen, bevor sie gehen. Na gut, jetzt wird es krass.
Manchmal muss man das aber auch glaube ich sein, oder?
Ja, es hilft zumindest, dann die Nerven zu bewahren, in manchen Situationen, kurz vor Autounfällen und so.
Also ihr seid Kinder der Funktion, aber so ganz unerfolgreich war das ja nicht. Wenn ihr mir diese lange Liste von Preisen anschaut, habt ihr sicherlich den einen oder anderen Sektkern schon mal in der Hand gehalten. Weiß nicht, was das für eine Bedeutung hat, aber Tatsache ist, ihr kommt, ihr seid zusammengekommen für ein Projekt, das heißt Angriff auf die Freiheit und es geht über Sicherheitswahn, über Wachensstaat und Abbau bürgerlicher Rechte. Das ist ja hier auch regelmäßig Thema, nicht regelmäßig genug eigentlich. Und was ist eigentlich los? Also was ist eigentlich los in diesem Land, fragt man sich manchmal, dass das irgendwie alles so haltlos ist. Ich hatte ja schon jetzt verschiedene Sendungen, insbesondere werdet ihr auch alles mitbekommen haben, diese Censursela-Debatte, die so ein bisschen den Anschein macht, als ob sich da jetzt auf einmal ein bisschen das Geröll gelöst hat in diesem unbeweglichen Benutzerberg des Internets so und so ein lawinenartiger Effekt losgeht. Man weiß bloß nicht so richtig, ob der jetzt auf halber Strecke dann wieder verreckt oder ob das noch mal donnernd ins Tal rauschen wird. Das bleibt an dieser Stelle glaube ich auch offen. Aber ihr habt ja nun eigentlich eine ganz andere Position. Also ihr seid jetzt noch nicht seit 20 Jahren im Internet unterwegs und ihr habt irgendwie nicht schon die ganze Zeit, was weiß ich, die Paranoia geschoben. Vielleicht auch schon, ich weiß es nicht. Was führt euch zu diesem Thema? Wie kommt man auf einmal so aus dieser Fiktionswelt, wo man immer mal wieder ein anderes Thema hat, zu so einem Sachding?
Du hast gerade mit deiner Frechheit die ersten drei Jahre im Arbeitslager waren die Schlechtsten.
Und dann beschloss ich, jetzt muss ich was tun.
Nein, also jetzt muss ich leider bulgurtieren. Aber das wäre ja unfair gegenüber den ganzen Zuhörern.
Wenn du nichts sagen würdest, komm jetzt erzählen. Aber warum interessierst du dich überhaupt für diesen Müll?
Wie seid ihr auf die China angekommen? Ihr seid euch ja in China begegnet, weil in China wäre Auslöser oder was?
Nein, wir haben uns beide schon lange damit beschäftigt.
Also seid eigentlich seit hierher, würde ich sagen.
Ich kann das gar nicht mehr zurückdatieren. Ich weiß nicht den Schlüsselmoment oder das Erlebnis, wo ich dachte, ey jetzt rückt mir hier irgendwas so massiv auf die Pelle. Jetzt werde ich langsam wirklich nervös. Ich weiß nicht wann das war. Aber es war jedenfalls schon vor dem 11. September, glaube ich.
Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich leider hier eine Geschichte filmen kann. Als Flüchtling hat man ja so einen Flüchtlingsausweis. Du bist ja Doktorin der Juris Podenz und dir ist das geläufig. Das ist irgendwie von den deutschen Behörden ausgestellt, aber das ist ein Vertrag mit der UNHCR, also mit der United Nations High Commission of Refugees. Und mit diesem Ausweis ist man wirklich ein Bürger, ein Mensch zweiter Klasse. Das merkt man, wenn man das Land verlässt. Ich war Student in München und hatte irgendwie nicht beachtet, dass ich für...
Warte mal, merkt man, wenn man welches Land verlässt?
Deutschland, weil Deutschland hatten wir Asyl bekommen.
Das heißt, du hattest hier Flüchtlingsstatus?
Ich hatte in Deutschland den Status eines Asylanten. Und um Deutschland zu verlassen, konnte ich natürlich nur mit diesem Ausweis...
Braucht man eine Genehmigung?
So, nicht eine Genehmigung. Es gibt Länder, die ein ganz schwer zu bekommendes Visum verlangen, damals die Österreicher. Und ich hatte das nicht gewusst. Ich hatte mich auch nicht informiert. Und ich war in Italien. Auf der Hinreise hat mich einfach niemand kontrolliert. Auf der Rückreise, ich als armer Student, hatte wirklich keinen Pfennig mehr in der Tasche. Am Brenner, mitten in der Nacht, wachen sie einen auf. Bevor ich noch irgendwas sagen konnte, haben sie mich gepackt und richtig rausgeworfen. Also wie in so einer Kinoszene. Und den Rucksack hinterher. Und ich irgendwie versuche, illegal und so weiter in das Land einzureisen. Ich habe versucht, ihnen zu erklären, wie der Zusammenhang ist, dass ich nach Deutschland will, dass ich überhaupt nicht österreichisch betreten will. Hat die überhaupt nicht interessiert. Ich sollte zurück nach Mailand fahren und mir dort im österreichischen Konsulat ein Visum besorgen.
Wann war das?
Und das war 1985, glaube ich. Und ich hatte kein Geld und wie nach Mailand kommen und so weiter. Dann habe ich den Fehler gemacht, zu versuchen, illegal auf den nächsten Zug darauf zu springen. Dann haben sie mich erwischt, die haben patuliert, auch mit so großen Scheinwerfen oder großen Taschenlampen. Und dann wurden sie wirklich pampig. Also haben mich zwar nicht geschlagen, aber schon ein bisschen so hin und her geschoben und so. Und wurden auch im Ton sehr unangenehm. Und ich war ziemlich ratlos. Ich war irgendwie so 19 oder 20. Und Gott sei Dank, und das ist jetzt der Punkt, wo die die befreiende Kraft der Fiktion ins Spiel kommt, habe ich mich erinnert an einen Krimi, wo da irgendwie es eine Rolle spielte, dass man mit den Truckern ganz leicht die Grenze überwinden kann, weil die Trucker sozusagen ihren Laster irgendwo stehen lassen, reingehen für die ganzen Dokumente und dann mit dem Laster durchfahren. Und außerdem hatte ich so, seit ich Convoy gesehen habe, diese Vision, dass Trucker ja eh ein bisschen anarchistisch angehaucht sind, das heißt, die hätten Verständnis für mich, war tatsächlich so, ich bin hingegangen und habe gesagt, ich muss da jetzt illegal durch Österreich. Der Typ war, kein Problem, komm steig ein. Und dann bin ich sozusagen durch Österreich gekommen. Aber das sind jetzt, ich will nicht behaupten, dass mich groß traumatisiert hätte oder sonst, aber das sind so kleine Erlebnisse, die einem so ein gewisses, ein gewissen, glaube ich, sehr gesunden, ein gewisses gesundes Misstrauen gegenüber Behörden und ihren Machtpositionen beziehungsweise auch ihr Verhalten und auch den Möglichkeiten oder den Gefahren des Machtmissbrauchs einbläut. Und ich glaube, es ist bei Juli ähnlich, so empfinde ich das bei dir immer wieder, dass wir beide, glaube ich, so eine gewisse skeptische, kritische Grundhaltung haben, die meiner Ansicht nach auch gar nicht außergewöhnlich ist. Ich würde sagen, das sollte eigentlich selbstverständlich sein.
Man denkt, das ist normal, ist es aber eben eigentlich überhaupt nicht mehr.
Aber ich würde schon sagen, zu einem aufgeklärten, kritischen, freiheitlich gesinnten Geist gehört so ein gesundes Misstrauen und Skepsis.
Wem gegenüber?
Ja, gegenüber all jenen, die Machtposition haben, ob es jetzt staatlich oder privatwirtschaftlicher Art ist, ist sozusagen noch eine zweite Frage.
Und aus meiner Sicht schon besonders auch gegenüber staatlicher Machtkonzentration und vor allem gegenüber dem Bestreben, diese Macht zu vergrößern. Ich habe halt, wie gesagt, keine schmucken Starreldraht-Geschichten, aber bin dafür als gutes Westmädchen eben auch in meinem Leben lang erzogen worden im Geiste dieses Misstrauens gegenüber dem Staat, was in Deutschland ja auch aus gewissen historischen Erfahrungen herrührt, mit dem wir dann im Nachhinein dachten, doch nicht mehr ganz so einverstanden zu sein. Also wurde quasi sowieso aufgebracht in diesem Gefühl, wenn dir einer über die Schulter guckt, wenn dir einer zu nahe rückt, du musst deine persönliche Freiheit dem gegenüber verteidigen. Und zwar nicht nur aus Egoismus oder weil du gerne dich selbst verwirklichen willst und weil du nicht willst, dass dir jemand Vorschriften macht, sondern auch, weil das ein politischer Akt ist, der über dich hinausweist. Also indem du quasi deine persönliche Freiheit schützt, schützt du irgendwie auch unser demokratisches System. Das ist deine Verantwortung. So habe ich mir das immer vorgestellt. Das war mein Weltbild. Und nach der Wende in den Lauf der 90er und dann erst recht nach dem 11. September hat sich um mich herum in einem so rasanten Tempo was verändert. Also da haben sich nicht nur jetzt konkrete Terrorgesetze und irgendwelche Maßnahmen sind erlassen worden, sondern auch das Denken, das Reden, die gesamte Stimmung, die Mentalität im Land hat sich aus meiner Sicht um 180 Grad gedreht innerhalb kürzester Zeit. Und ich habe wirklich gedacht, ich sehe nicht richtig. Also ich war geschockt. Ich konnte es gar nicht glauben, was da los ist. Und es folgte eine lange Zeit der Fassungslosigkeit und irgendwann dann das Gefühl so, jetzt muss man halt mal was sagen oder so.
Aber es war doch nicht das erste Mal. Ich meine, wir hatten das so nun auch schon in den 70er-Jahren.
Da gab es mich aber noch nicht. Also das war jetzt wirklich quasi persönliche Genese. Natürlich guckt man dann irgendwann zurück und erkennt, aha, natürlich, solche Tendenzen sind sowieso normal. Die gehen über die Jahrzehnte. Aber was jetzt schon anders ist seit den 90ern und speziell jetzt in diesem Jahrzehnt, in den 70ern und in den 80ern gab es immer Proteste dagegen. Das hat sich irgendwie ausbalanciert. Also ich meine, wir hatten in den 70ern RF-Terror. Das wurde natürlich zum Anlass genommen, ganz viel zu verändern, auch auf gesetzlicher Ebene, neue Eingriffsbefugnisse zu schaffen. Aber selbst damals, und der RF-Terror war ja etwas, was Deutschland viel mehr betroffen hat als heute der islamistische sogenannte Terror. Trotzdem gab es damals breite Gruppen, sogar Rechtsanwälte, also gestandene Mitglieder der Gesellschaft, die sich getraut haben zu sagen, so nicht, Notstandsgesetzgebung, das wollen wir nicht. Das kannst du heute öffentlich nicht mehr sagen. Da wirst du ja quasi angeschwärzt, dass du irgendwie ein Staatsfeind bist, ich übertreib jetzt ein bisschen. Also der Konsens heute darüber, dass das gut und richtig ist, den Staat immer weiter zu stärken gegen diese Bedrohungen, den finde ich erschreckend breit und homogen. Das ist es, was mich eigentlich mehr geschockt hat, als die Tatsache, dass es Tendenzen gibt, die Macht auszuweiten. Die gibt es wahrscheinlich wirklich immer.
Und so sie übertreibst du gar nicht. Also ich wurde schon ein paar Mal angegriffen in diesem Zusammenhang nach Kommentaren oder Artikeln, die erzählen von mir von Leuten, die dann behauptet haben, a, das sei Wehrkraft-Zersetzung. Ich kann mich genau an den einen Satz erinnern, da endete die, in einem konservativen Blatt endete die Kritik damit, so wollen wir weiter suchen lesen, während wir auf den nächsten Terroranschlag warten. Und da war sozusagen der ganze Tenor des Artikels, Leute wie Trojanow sind unglaublich gefährlich, weil sie sozusagen als Gutmenschen irgendwie auf Dialog und Verständnis und Informationen und so weiter setzen. Und genau das hilft den Terroristen, die aufgrund sozusagen der Schwächung der Gesellschaft, solche Menschen den nächsten Terroranschlag erfolgreich vorbereiten. Oder neulich wieder von einem gar nicht so unbekannten Autorenkollegen, der dann auf seinem Blog behauptet hat, eigentlich sei mein Ziel mit genau diesem Thema, wo ja Islam überhaupt nicht vorkommt, mein Ziel sei es, Europa für den Islam zu öffnen.
Wir sind Islamisten-Versteher und so. Oder was man auch hört, das war auch heute übrigens oft in den Fragen der Journalisten, die uns gestellt wurden, sind immer wieder suggestiv mit enthalten, wir seien quasi Paranoiker oder Verschwörungstheoretiker. Also wir wollten suggerieren, es gebe irgendeine dunkle Weltverschwörung und das wurde immer dann schon angebracht und sehr abwertend. Also nicht als Frage, sondern eher so nach dem Motto, naja, komm, das ist doch jetzt wieder hier irgendeine Verschwörungstheorie. Das wurde immer dann angebracht, wenn man überhaupt gar nichts in diese Richtung gesagt hat. Also man sagt quasi, beim einen konkreten Fall, was irgendwie das Ilija kritisch anmerkte, dass das Phänomen der Massenmedien natürlich auch sehr dazu neigt, zu einer bestimmten Art von Indoktrinierung der Öffentlichkeit oder sowas zu taugen, daraufhin, ja, das ist doch jetzt wieder nur irgendeine Verschwörungstheorie. Also das ist auch ein Argument, mit dem man häufig versucht, Leute mundtot zu machen, die in irgendeiner Weise kritisch darüber sind.
Noam Chomsky hat ja mal zum Verschwörung diesen wunderbaren Satz gesagt, dass die Kritik, dass er eine Verschwörungstheorie immer dann kommt vom Establishment. Wenn man einfach nicht mehr weiter weiß, wenn man sozusagen eine solide, formulierte und durchargumentierte Kritik sich gegenüber sieht und man hat sozusagen, man kann diese Kritik nicht selber dekonstruieren. Also behauptet man, ahja, eine große Verschwörungstheorie.
Du sagst ja, in dem Moment, derjenige ist krank. Ich meine, jemand, der Verschwörungstheorien tatsächlich hat, ist ein Paranoiker, der ist klinisch krank. Also wenn dich jemand so was fragt, wenn man ganz streng sezieren will, was da für eine Message drüber kommt, heißt das, Junge, du bist in Wahrheit nicht ganz bei Trost. Du bildest dir Sachen ein und du spinnst. Das ist schon eine Argumentationslinie, die wir kennen aus Zeiten, wo Leute, die kritisch waren, einfach mal als Verrückte abgestempelt und entsprechend behandelt worden sind. Ich will es jetzt nicht hochzonen, aber es ist eben schon so, dass eine Gesprächskultur, eine offene Gesprächskultur, wo man sich entspannt austauschen kann, nicht gerade die Regel ist im Bereich dieses Themas. Und ich glaube, das ist eine recht neue Entwicklung. Die war, denke ich mal, in den 70er, 80er nicht so virulent wie heute.
Das mag sein.
Ich weiß nicht, war nicht dabei.
Ich war auch nicht dabei. Also ich war zwar dabei, aber ich war da auch noch irgendwie ganz lüt.
Was für ein Jahr, bis zu?
67.
Wir sind auch nur sieben Jahre auseinander oder so. Naja, eine kleine Generation, ein kleines Generationchen dazwischen. Aber ich will nicht sagen, dass ich damals schon aktiv irgendwie an der politischen Diskussion teilgenommen habe. Nö, kann ich nicht verhaupen. Aber trotzdem bleibt ja auch was von hängen und man sieht ja auch ganz konkret, welche Gesetze sind beschlossen worden. Ja, unabhängig davon, welche gesellschaftliche Diskussions darum gab, hat sich ja auch durchaus eine Änderung eingestellt und es ist halt immer damit verbunden, es gibt eine neue Gefahr und das ist die große Diskussion und dann muss halt was getan werden angeblich. Muss immer irgendwas getan werden. Ich weiß nicht, warum immer was getan werden muss, aber es behauptet, dass man immer was tun müsse, weil sonst würde man ja nichts tun und das geht ja auch nicht und das Einzige, was man dann tun kann, offensichtlich scheint ja zu sein, mehr Kontrolle auszuüben. Also ich finde allein schon diesen Begriff wehrhafter Staat, den finde ich ja auch schon schon geil, weil er ja sozusagen impliziert, dass dieser, also auf mich macht das zumindest so den Eindruck, als würde der Staat permanent in so einer Verteidigungsrolle sein. Von allen Seiten würde jetzt alles auf ihn eindreschen und er müsse halt die ganze Zeit zurückschlagen und man dürfte ihm doch jetzt irgendwie nicht den Hammer wegnehmen, weil sonst kann er nicht mehr zuschlagen. Was mir dabei immer so fehlt, wie auch bei vielen anderen Bildern, die mit verbunden sind, ist so diese, was ist denn eigentlich der Staat? Also wo wohnt der, hat er eine Adresse irgendwie so? Wo wurde der geboren? Ist denn der Staat nicht sowieso wir alle? Warum gibt es denn da diese Unterscheidung? Habt ihr euch mit diesem Staatsverständnis auch auseinandergesetzt?
Also im Buch steht, da ist ja keine Analyse drin, aber wir haben beide darüber natürlich eine Menge nachgedacht. Das sind Fragen, die sich aufdrängen. Wer ist das überhaupt? Gerät man selber ein Feindbild der Staat, wenn man quasi überhaupt so redet. Aus meiner Sicht ist das einzig demokratisch sinnvolle Staatsverständnis natürlich, dass der Staat sind wir alle. Der setzt sich zusammen aus dem Kollektiv der Bürger, die sich laut Grundgesetz auch selber die Gesetze geben. Die Gewalt soll ja vom Volke ausgehen. Es ist aber tatsächlich zunehmend so, dass in der Rhetorik und dadurch auch in den Köpfen der Leute ein Antagonismus aufgemacht wird. Der Staat ist wirklich ständig in dieser Verteidigungsposition. Es werden ja auch Begriffe benutzt, die noch hinausgehen über Selbstverteidigung oder Wehrhaftigkeit. Das sind schon Begriffe, die schlimm genug sind. Es wird ja auch von Kampf und von Krieg gesprochen. Wir leben ja jetzt im Kriegszustand in einem Zustand quasi militärischer Selbstverteidigung, wobei eben das Fatale ist oder das Neue, dass dieser Krieg jetzt eben nicht mehr zwischen Staaten geführt wird, wie das eben traditionell bis 1990 in den Köpfen der Fall war. Da haben wir uns ja immer verteidigt gegen den kommunistischen Feind von außen. Den gibt es jetzt nicht mehr und jetzt gibt es halt diesen neuen Krieg und der richtet sich nach innen, gewissermaßen. Weil der Terrorist, der Schläfer, dieser Virus, der quasi die Gesellschaft von innen infiltriert und von innen auffrisst, ist ja unter uns. Das heißt, es gibt jetzt auf einmal eben den Staat, der sich nach innen verteidigt und nicht mehr nach außen. Und wer ist denn innen? Innen ist ja der Bürger eigentlich, es sei denn, man nennt ihn Terrorist, dann ist es auf einmal kein Bürger mehr. Das heißt, da ist auf einmal so ein antagonistisches Denken, der wirklich mit Kampfrhetorik und militärischer Kriegsrhetorik.
Krieg gegen den Terror, ne?
Das ist Krieg gegen den Terror.
Also diese militärische Metaphorik oder Rhetorik ist enorm wichtig, weil sie ja sowohl auf dieser medialen Ebene stattfindet, in der Kommunikation, aber auch im wirklichen Leben. Es ist ja ganz, ja, also für mich ernüchternd, um nicht zu sagen, wirklich schockierend zu sehen, dass 1989 es tatsächlich einige Jahre gab, in denen die Militärausgaben und Militärexporte weltweit runtergegangen sind, wo man wirklich Hoffnung haben konnte, dass dieser Wahnsinn jetzt nach dem Ende des Kalten Krieges in irgendeiner Art und Weise in eine friedliche, die Ressourcen anders nutzende Weltgesellschaft umgewandelt wird. Und damals, ich kann mich sehr erinnern, es hat mich sehr beeinflusst, ein Interview, ich glaube Anfang der 90er Jahre, mit einem amerikanischen General, wo der Journalist gefragt hat, naja, ich meine, was für einen Auftrag haben sie jetzt? Eigentlich gibt es sozusagen keinen Feind mehr. Und der Mann hat dann gesagt, von wegen, die Feinde sind jetzt viel schlimmer, weil wir sie nicht sehen. Sie sind überall, überall. Und wir müssen im Gegenteil, wir müssen uns auf neue Aufgaben vorbereiten, aber der Feind, gucken sie sich mal die gesamte dritte Welt an, überall dort lauert der Feind. Also ich perfosiere, weil ich es jetzt nicht genau hinkriege, aber genau das war Thema. Und so ist es wirklich, genauso ist es passiert. Es hat sozusagen eine tatsächliche Remilitarisierung gegeben. Die Militärausgaben in den letzten zehn Jahren sind ja explodiert von den ganzen großen Staaten dieser Welt und es hat gleichzeitig im öffentlichen Diskurs eine Remilitarisierung der Sprache gegeben. Und beide Sachen gehen Hand in Hand und sind inzwischen wirklich erschreckend. Gerade auch wegen dem, was wir vorhin gesagt haben, weil es kaum eine gesellschaftliche Widerstandsbewegung gibt, die sich dem entgegenstellt.
Ja und weil es beliebig geworden ist. Weil wenn man sagt, der Feind ist unsichtbar, der Feind ist im Inneren, der Feind ist subversiv, der Feind ist der Terrorist, dann sind es ja komplette Worthülsen, unter die du ja jeden drunter packen kannst. Also je nach Geschmacksrichtung. Und wir sehen ja glücklicherweise vornehmlich bislang in anderen Staaten, zum Beispiel in Großbritannien, aber Anzeichen gibt es auch hier. Und ich denke mal, wir nehmen da alle eine ähnliche Entwicklung. Also die ganze westliche Welt ist da in einem Trend befangen, dass tatsächlich jetzt dieser Feind, der ursprünglicher der islamistische Terrorist war, auch schon anders verortet wird. Also das können jetzt eben auch schon ökologische Bewegungen sein, die irgendeine Aktion starten, wo dann auf einmal behauptet wird, das sind ja Terroristen. Die haben ja irgendwie ein Schloss an der Tür mit Sprühfarbe gekennzeichnet. Das ist ja Vandalismus, also Terrorismus. Also wenden wir die Terrorgesetze an. Oder noch harmlosere Dinge, die einfach nur im Bereich alltäglichen Fehlverhaltens liegen.
Das ist jetzt eine Vermutung von dir?
Such mal kurz die Zitate mit den Quellen und ich erzähle derweil noch ein bisschen. Also es gibt in Großbritannien halt diesen Begriff, das Anti-Social-Behaviour. Das ist eine stehende Wendung. Also das ist sozusagen kein retorischer Begriff, sondern ein juristischer. Darunter wird alles mögliche Verhalten gepackt. Zum Beispiel lärmende Kinder, wenn jemand Pizza draußen verkauft, der hat keine Lizenz, wenn du irgendwie lärmende Kinder hast. Anti-Social-Behaviour. Also alles, was stört. Also was sozusagen der Hausmeister... Nein, ne Moment. Also das ist sozusagen erstmal der Tatbestand, wie die Juristen sagen würden. Und was jetzt angewendet wird von manchen Gemeinden, sind die Anti-Terror-Gesetze. Die werden angewendet auf Fälle von sogenanntem Anti-Social-Behaviour. Was dazu führt, dass eben in Tatbeständen, wo zum Beispiel Lärm produziert wird, und es gibt einen konkreten Fall, wo das auch wirklich Kinderlärm war, dann die Behörden, die Polizei, Videokameras aufstellen, um das zu beobachten, um Beweise zu sammeln, wessen Kinder das sind, ob die tatsächlich außerhalb der Ruhezeiten oder Inhalte, wie auch immer. Also die ermitteln und verfolgen diese Alltagstatbestände unter Anwendung der Anti-Terror-Gesetze. Und es gibt inzwischen 850 Fälle, in denen das eben so gehandhabt worden ist.
1867, ja. Also das heißt...
Also wir reden nicht über Fiktion, wir reden über konkrete juristische Praxis oder polizeiliche Praxis.
Das heißt, also das Gesetz oder die Vorlage Regulation of Investigatory Powers Act, kurz RIPA, und das sind jetzt ein paar Beispiele für Leute, die gelten sozusagen als Anti-Terror- Gesetze, aber folgende Bürger wurden mit Hilfe dieser Gesetze verfolgt, zum Beispiel jemand, der Müll auf die Straße geworfen hat, Hunderhaufen nicht fortschrittsmäßig entsorgt, illegal Pizza verkauft, Kinder, die beim Fußballspielen von statischen Kameras gefilmt wurden, weil das Geschrei die Kinder belästigt hat, Eltern werden ausgespäht, das ist, finde ich, auch unglaublich. Eltern werden ausgespäht, weil man herausfinden wollte, ob sie ihre Kinder an einer Schule außerhalb des zugewiesenen Bezirkes angemeldet haben. Das heißt, allein in der ersten Jahreshälfte 2008 waren das 867 Terror-Ermittlungsverfahren gegen solche Alltagssünder. Und es gibt ja auch, also mein Lieblingsbeispiel, weil ich das so wirklich absurd finde, wie aus einer Monty-Python-Sendung, ist das tatsächlich die englische Regierung unter Gordon Brown mit dem Anti-Terror-Gesetz, die isländischen Banken, insoweit sie in England sind, hat einfrieren lassen.
Und zwar glaube ich ausdrücklich mit der Ansage, das ist ein terroristischer Staat.
Genau, indem man gesagt hat, Island ist ein Terrorstaat, also können wir alle Konten einfrieren. Das Verrückte ist, dass Island neben Costa Rica der einzige Staat auf der Welt ist, der keine Armee hat. Das ist sozusagen ein vorbildlicher, friedlicher Staat.
Das ist doch verdächtig.
Das würde ich aber auch sagen. Der Feind wohnt schließlich im Inneren.
Das ist ein Beweis für Terrorismus. Besser gibt es gar nicht.
Diese Islander.
Die haben bestimmt etwas zu verbergen. Ja, man sieht daran einfach sehr schön, dass dieser Begriff des unsichtbaren Feindes oder wie auch immer man das grad rhetorisch wenden möchte, eben extrem bequem ist, dehnbar und in jede Richtung anzuwenden und das ist was.
also die Situation in Britannien ist ja nun schon seit längerer Zeit so ein bisschen out of control, habe ich so das Gefühl. Ich habe es jetzt im Einzelnen so nicht verfolgt. Ihr habt ja da zumindest ein paar Fälle rausgesucht. Was bitte geht denn da ab? Also habt ihr da irgendwie eine Ahnung oder eine Vorstellung oder eine Theorie, was eigentlich dort gesellschaftlich passiert, dass es so weit kommt?
Müssen wir über Großbritannien reden? Wir reden allgemein.
Schwierig, ja. Ich glaube, da kennen wir England auch nicht gut genug. Also ich zumindest nicht, um das zu analysieren.
Wir müssen es nicht so sehr an Britannien festmachen. Also es ist ja ein Trend, der dort offensichtlich schon ein bisschen weiter ist. Ich meine, das ist natürlich besonders lustig, in Einführungsstrichen, das ist ausgerechnet England, wo George Orwell nun ein Stück weit Visionen schon längst zu Papier gebracht hat.
Ja, und wo die Demokratie auch erfunden wurde, könnte man ja bei einer von Worten als eine alte Tradition...
Ja, vor allem das sehr wichtige, habeus corpus, das finde ich ein schönes Detail, was wir zufällig entdeckt haben, das in dem Jahr, in dem George Bush zum ersten Mal seit 300 Jahren im anglosächsischen Recht habeus corpus wieder aus den Angeln gehoben hat. Das ist ein... Ja, vielleicht du als Doktor der US-Pundese.
Ja, das ist mal auf, du Migrant. Du kannst ja nicht mal richtig sprechen. Also es geht da konkret um diese Regel, die wir ja alle wichtig finden, nach unserem demokratischen Verständnis, dass man Menschen nicht beliebig von zu Hause abholen und einsperren darf. Das ist es im Wesentlichen. Wir rollen jetzt nicht die Historie auf, sondern wir sagen nur, worum es geht. Man darf sie nicht festhalten, man darf sie nicht verhaften. Man muss Gründe dafür haben und so fort. Dass der Staat nicht willkürlich Menschen inhaftieren darf, weil das eines der schlimmsten Druckmittel ist, das sieht man ja auch in Staaten, in denen es nicht besonders gut läuft, dass das ständig passiert. Leute verschwinden, heißt es dann ja immer, werden möglicherweise gefoltert oder getötet. Man weiß es einfach nicht. Sie sind erstmal weg. Und das ist halt eine grauenvolle Drohung für den Einzelnen. Das wollen wir nicht. Deswegen gab es immer in den Verfassungen Regeln, die dem Staat genau das verbieten. Und das hat George Bush dann ja aufgehoben, damit er diese Guantanamo-Schurse durchziehen kann. Weil die ja alle inhaftiert werden, ohne richterliches Urteil. Und darauf wolltest du hinaus pikanterweise...
Genau, und in dem Jahr wurde von Thorsobes in New York das Original dieses...
Der Magna Carta.
Der Magna Carta war das erste Mal, es ist überhaupt in 1215 in England von King John, also König Johannes, überhaupt eingeführt wurde. Auf Tuck des Adels wurde das für 21 Millionen verscherbelt.
Also der Staat hat das verkauft?
Nein, nein, nein. Das war wahrscheinlich im Besitz...
Das ist einfach eine Auktion, das ist eben ein altes, historisches Stück.
Weil du Orville gesagt hast, nur ein ganz kurzes Zitat aus dem Buch, weil ich das einfach herrlich finde. Er hat ja gewohnt im Norden Londons. Ein Haus mit der Nummer 27B am Cannonberry Square. Und da hat er gelebt bis zu seinem Tod, 1950. Und dort hat er auch 1984 geschrieben. Und wenn man dort vor dem Haus steht und einfach so einmal um den Park herumgeht, also um den Platz herumgeht, gibt es dort 32 CCTV-Cameras.
Heute?
Heute, 32 Stück. Und wenn man in seine Lieblingskneipe geht, die heißt The Compton Arms, gibt es also direkt vor der Kneipe auch eine Kamera, die überprüft, wer den Papp wann betritt und wann wieder verlässt. Inzwischen, übrigens fand ich auch ein interessantes Detail, inzwischen muss man in London bei der Polizei, also verlangt die Polizei von dem Besitzer einer Gaststätte, dass er so eine Kamera installiert, sonst geben sie einem die Lizenz nicht.
Man muss eine Kamera installieren?
Genau. Also in bestimmten Teilen London, sonst kriegt man die Lizenz nicht. Das heißt, wenn man sich das wirklich vorstellt, was mich immer fasziniert hat, schon als Kind, ist die Idee der Zeitreise. Also wenn Orwell jetzt plötzlich da irgendwie heute hinkommt, der wäre wirklich geschockt. Der würde wirklich sagen, okay.
Der wird sich freuen. Ich hab's ja immer gesagt.
Ja, aber ich glaube schon, dass er ein Moralist war. Ich glaube schon, dass ihn das schocken würde.
Ich glaube auch, dass er geschockt wäre. Aber wir wollen eigentlich über die Frage reden, warum das so ist.
Genau. Also was passiert mit einer Gesellschaft, was du jetzt auch benannt hast, mit Bush und 2001, da wird jetzt immer viel drauf festgemacht. Zu Recht sicherlich, ja...
Siehst du, du kriegst auch schon wieder Schiss. Man muss immer sagen, bei 2001, da ist ja auch richtig, dass man das verfolgt. Und die bösen Terroristen...
Hab ich nicht gesagt.
Du hast aber gesagt, zu Recht. Man könnte ja auch sagen, das ist alles totaler Quatsch. Das bringt sowieso nichts in der Terrorkrieg.
Darauf hab ich mich gar nicht bezogen. Ich wollte... das hast du mich ein bisschen aus meinem Fluss rausgebracht. Nee, ich... also zu Recht bezog ich da drauf. Zu Recht macht sich natürlich viel daran fest, dass es da so eine Zeitenwende gab. Aber es ist ja auch nicht so, dass das nun vorher überhaupt nicht da gewesen wäre. Also diese Debatte mit Einschränkungen der Privatsphäre und so weiter, das hat ja im Kleinen auch schon immer stattgefunden. Und man kann auch sagen, die Geschwindigkeit, mit der Gesetzes-Novellen dann in die Öffentlichkeit gebracht wurden bzw. dann auch beschlossen wurden, nachdem, wenn man sich anschaut, wie lange es dauert, normalerweise ein Gesetz auszuhandeln, da fragt man sich, wo lagen denn bitte diese Gesetzesinitiativen die ganze Zeit rum?
Nee, das war aber nicht so. Was wirklich passiert ist, ist, dass die, also da haben wir heute ja auch kurz mit Frau Leutherser-Schnarenberger drüber gesprochen, die hat das auch nochmal erzählt, das erzählen einem ganz viele Abgeordnete, dass seit dem 11. September werden Gesetze echt in einem sozusagen leicht veränderten Verfahren erlassen. Also die Abgeordneten kriegen die zum Teil am gleichen Tag, wo dann die Abstimmung sein soll, weil das so schnell durchgepeitscht wird. Diese Gesetze werden so schnell zusammengestoppelt. Die lagen nicht schon in Schubladen bereit, sondern die wurden einfach dann unter dem Druck der aufgeheizten öffentlichen Meinung wirklich richtig durch den Durchlauferhitzer gejagt. Und zwar in einer Art von Verfahren, wo man als Jurist sagen muss, da kann man eigentlich schon bezweifeln, ob dieses Gesetzgebungsverfahren überhaupt noch verfassungsgemäß ist, weil man den Abgeordneten doch ein bisschen Zeit geben muss, da wenigstens mal reinzugucken. Das sind zum Teil ja Klopper von irgendwie 150 Seiten oder noch mehr. Die kannst du doch nicht auf den Tisch knallen und sagen, und jetzt stimmen wir aber ab, pronto. Weil das schnell gehen muss. Und das wurde auch zwischendurch immer wieder von Abgeordneten der Grünen zum Beispiel moniert. Die haben dann versucht, sich dagegen zu wehren und zu sagen, das könnt ihr so nicht machen, das ist nicht seriös und auch nicht verfassungsmäßig. Da hat sich wirklich damals geändert.
Okay, ich will aber trotzdem noch mal ein bisschen auf diese, was geht denn eigentlich in der Gesellschaft vor, nochmal raus. Okay, 70er Jahre bist du, sagst du, willst sie nicht zu äußern, aber irgendwann muss es bei dir ja auch mal eingesetzt haben, dass du deine Gesellschaft umfangreich wahrgenommen hast. 80er Jahre wahrscheinlich, und da stelle ich jetzt mal so. Was ist dir denn aufgefallen? Ich meine, vielleicht war das für dich jetzt auch nicht so ein Thema, aber gut, war es jetzt im Westen, du hast ein Stück weit Default-Freiheit genossen. Mir ging es nicht ähnlich. Viele Sachen waren einfach selbstverständlich. Und in der Nazizeit, okay, alles klar, das kriegt man dann zwar in der Schule und in der Tagesschau regelmäßig um die Ohren gehauen, aber es war halt nicht wirklich jetzt so ein Thema die ganze Zeit. Also es war ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt irgendwie unmittelbar irgendwas davon wahrnahmen, so jetzt mal so von Neonazi-Diskussion mal ganz abgesehen. Ist das so eine Verweichlichung, die da stattgefunden hat, dass man dann einfach nur noch Fernsehen geguckt hat und einem ist irgendwie alles egal? Ich meine, warum, gerade wenn man das so genießt mit diesen Freiheiten, dann müsste es einem ja doch gerade besonders nahe gehen.
Es müsste wehtun, wenn die eingeschränkt werden, das ist, was ich erwartet habe. Also was ein Unterschied ist und jetzt, also wir reden dann auch gleich, wir tasten uns ran, woran es liegen könnte, aber es ist echt eine schwierige Frage, woran das vielleicht liegt, weil das ist quasi eine massenpsychologische Frage, da können wir nun spekulieren. Was ich aber wirklich glaube, warzunehmen, jetzt vor dem Hintergrund eben dieser sozusagen westdeutschen Biografie, dass in den 80ern und auch bis weit in die 90er hinein hatten die Leute einfach keine Angst. Und ich meine jetzt nicht nur vor Terroristen, sondern generell, also was hat man so gedacht mit 17, 18 Jahren von der Welt? Man hat gedacht, ja ich bin so hier, wir waren auch gar nicht apolitisch, wir haben uns total für Politik interessiert, nur nicht so sehr für Innenpolitik. Wir fanden den Golfkrieg ganz schlimm. Also Außenpolitik war ein Riesenthema. Darüber wurde in der Schule, also nicht im Unterricht, sondern unter uns Schülern ständig diskutiert. Also es gab absolut politisches Bewusstsein. Wir sind auch auf Demos gegangen und so. Und von unserem eigenen Leben haben wir gedacht, so das lassen wir jetzt mal ganz ruhig anlaufen. Jetzt gehen wir vielleicht studieren und dann machen wir irgendeine Ausbildung und dann gucken wir mal was kommt und das wird sich schon alles irgendwie finden und so weiter. Also dieses Grundgefühl war erst mal, wir wollen uns entwickeln, wir wollen was sehen von der Welt, wir wollen mal gucken, wie es weitergeht. Seit einigen Jahren, wenn du mit 17-, 18-jährigen Leuten sprichst, die reden mit dir, als wären die irgendwie in einem Arbeitslager aufgewachsen. Das ist wirklich so, ja ich weiß nicht, ich hab so, die haben Angst. Die haben Angst vor ihrem eigenen Leben, die haben Angst vor der Zukunft, die haben Angst vor dem, was ihnen die Medien erzählen, was die Politik erzählt. Es herrscht eine grandiose, flächendeckende Verunsicherung. Und die macht die Leute stumm, glaube ich. Es geht nicht darum, ob die politisch oder apolitisch sind. Die 90er waren nicht so apolitisch und die 80er schon gar nicht, wie immer behauptet wird. Der große Unterschied ist, dass die Leute irgendwann angefangen haben, Angst zu bekommen. Das muss irgendwann Ende der 90er passiert sein.
Aber wovor?
Vor allem. Die haben irgendwie, ich glaube, das muss damit zusammenhängen, jetzt kommen wir an Spekulative. Ich meine, wir haben ja im Kalten Krieg gelebt. Da war die Bedrohung ja zwischenzeitlich auch mal recht virulent. Da gab es so Sachen wie Kuba-Krise, gut, das haben wir jetzt nicht so wach erlebt wie Jüngerinnen. Aber das waren Momente, wo man ja schon geglaubt hat, dieser dritte Weltkrieg ist möglich. Ich empfinde diese Bedrohung im Rückblick als realer als heute den Terroranschlag.
Ich würde auch sagen, es war auch in 80er Jahren noch ganz stark. Ich meine, es gab irgendwie die Aufrüstung, es gab irgendwie die Konfrontation.
Man wusste, die Raketen zielen genau dahin. Das habe ich als eine reale Bedrohung empfunden. Trotzdem war die Angst kleiner unter dieser realen Bedrohung. Oder sie hat sich irgendwie anders umgesetzt. Also man hat nicht zu Hause gesessen und gezittert und das Gefühl gehabt, wenn die Politik jetzt Gesetze erlässt, darf man nichts sagen und man muss irgendwie ständig aufpassen. Man hat das irgendwie von sich ferngehalten. Man hat eigentlich unter diesem Häuschen kalter Krieg recht ordentlich gelebt. Es war alles in Ordnung. Es gab die Russen und es gab die Amerikaner. Wir waren dummerweise dazwischen. Es gab das Weltbild Kommunismus, Kapitalismus. Das war so schön ordentlich. Vielleicht hängt es wirklich damit zusammen, dass dann im Lauf der 90er die Welt zu kompliziert wurde. Was für ein bescheuertes Satz. Als ob die Welt jemals einfach gewesen wäre.
Zumindest hat man sie einfach wahrgenommen.
Genau, man hat sie einfacher wahrgenommen.
Es war, dass das Feindbild war, was wir vorhin schon besprochen haben. Das war auf einmal weg.
Da ich zehn Jahre älter bin, muss ich mein Alter kurz ausschalten.
Was ist eigentlich dein Geburtsdatum noch mal?
65. Ich habe 1989 schon, auch was dieses Thema angeht, ganz wichtige Markierungen erlebt, weil die letzten, ich war in den 80er Jahren sehr aktiv tätig, im Nachhinein betrachtet wahrscheinlich eher lächerlichen bulgarischen Exilwiderstand. Wir haben etwas sich publiziert, illegal ins Land gebracht wie Papau. Es hat gereicht für eine Stasiakte, aber nicht, glaube ich, um in irgendeiner Art und Weise das bulgarische Regime zu beunruhigen. Aber ich hatte das Gefühl in den 80er Jahren, dass eigentlich der Kalte Krieg in eine sehr komode Phase getreten ist und dass beide Systeme sich sehr schön arrangiert haben, dass es insofern auch gar keinen Bedarf gab, sei es jetzt über öffentliche Medien, sei es in politischen Verlautbarungen, eigentlich in irgendeiner Art und Weise Feindbilder aufzubauen. Im Gegenteil, in den 80er Jahren, wenn ich zurückdenke, gab es ja eine Welle, ob es jetzt ein Hollywood-Film ist, ob es Bücher sind, ob es Begegnungen sind. Eine Welle eigentlich zu sagen, naja, der Ruski ist ja nicht so schlimm und sind ja nicht alle KGB und sind ja auch nur Menschen. Es gab eigentlich so, es gab auch keine anderen Feindbilder. Es war eigentlich so eine Welt, insofern stimme ich dir zu. Eine sehr bequeme Kommode, es gab zwar durchaus die einen oder anderen Probleme, aber wenn man sich überlegt, ich glaube, das, was die meisten bewegt hat Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er, war Atomkraft, nein, danke. Das heißt, es war ein eher technisches Problem, was sich auch leicht lösen lässt.
Es ging aber auch mit der atomalen militärischen Bedrohung zusammen, weil die eben schon wahrgenommen wurde.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass in den 80er-Jahren wirklich massenhaft die Leute geglaubt haben, dass es zu einem atomalen Weltkrieg zwischenden, also ich habe es zumindest nicht so wahrgenommen. Die andere Sache, die ich sehr intensiv wahrgenommen habe, ist, dass als jemand, der ganz, ganz oft nicht in Europa war und dann immer wieder zurückkehrte, dass viele Leute in Europa, auch nach 89, dachten, die Welt ist in Ordnung. Und ich werde nie vergessen, wie ein englischer Parlamentarier nach dem 11. September sagte, ab dem heutigen Tag ist sozusagen unsere schöne, heile Welt zerstört worden.
Ja, das habe ich schon ganz oft gehört.
Das habe ich auch ganz oft gehört. Und ich dachte mir um Gottes Willen, in was für einer Welt habt ihr gelebt. Das heißt, die Welt war wirklich in Sussex in Ordnung, vielleicht auch nur in kleinen Teilen von Sussex, aber ich glaube, in der Mentalität vieler Leute im sogenannten Westen gab es sozusagen eine schöne, heile, satte, geordnete Welt. Genau, ganz genau, das wollte ich gerade sagen. Und Ende der 90er plötzlich ganz, ganz viele Sachen passieren, wo man sagt, oh, das ist eine große Welt und da passieren ganz, ganz viele ganz schreckliche, ganz bedrohliche, überhaupt nicht kontrollierbare Sachen und die Welt. Und dann hat, glaube ich, der 11. September schon das nochmal ganz, ganz exemplarisch, symbolisch auf die Spitze getrieben. Die Gewalt, die wir fast auf der ganzen Welt haben, die Ungerechtigkeit, die wir auf der ganzen Welt haben, die kann sich entladen, auch bei uns. Wir sind alle potenziell in Gefahr, nicht nur jetzt wegen Terror, sondern in vielen verschiedenen Arten und Weisen. Und das steigert sich jetzt durch verschiedene Krisen, die jetzt kommen. Verschiedene ökologische Krisen, jetzt die Finanzkrise. Das heißt, wir haben jetzt eine Reihe von Krisen, unabhängig jetzt davon, wie real sie sind, auf jeden Fall in der Rhetorik, sehr hochgespitzte Krisen. Und insofern glaube ich schon, dass es auf einmal ein Gefühl gibt, naja, keiner ist mehr sicher.
Das ist ja nur eine Wahrnehmungsverschiebung. Es gab nicht früher mehr Krisen oder Katastrophen oder so. Genau, also da hat sich in den Köpfen der Leute was bewegt.
Ich meine, letztlich hängt immer davon ab, von wo man es sieht. Aber wenn man jetzt, sagen wir mal, allein die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung der Welt, da ist die Welt mehr zusammengekommen. Also mehr Länder sind reicher geworden. Und das geht nicht alles immer auseinander, wie man so schön sagt, die Schere, sondern tatsächlich ist es eigentlich auf einer globalen Ebene.
Nein, nein, die geht weit auseinander global. Das stimmt aber nicht. Also die Unterschiede zwischen sowohl in den einzelnen Ländern, als auch global gesehen, zwischen denen, die am besten verdienen und denen, die am wenigsten haben, die wächst unbeweglich.
Dann formulieren wir es anders und sagen sozusagen, die globale Mittelschicht ist breiter geworden. Also es gibt jetzt viel mehr Länder, die quasi mitspielen am globalen Wirtschaftsspiel, als es vorher gab.
Ja, es hängt jetzt immer ein bisschen davon ab, welche Statistik man anschaut. Ich kann euch da auch nach hinten nochmal was drauf verweisen. Also es ist schon, es gibt natürlich einen großen Unterschied zwischen den beiden Extremen. Gar keine Frage, der wird auch noch eine ganze Weile so bleiben. Aber wie du schon sagst, so im Mittelbau. Also es ist schon etwas in Bewegung. Und man kann zumindest jetzt nicht generell sagen, indem man jetzt mal so eben locker auf die Welt schaut, es gibt auch wirklich den Anlass für diese Unmittelbarheit.
Ich würde sogar sagen, im Gegenteil. Also nach dem Kalten Krieg müsste man doch eigentlich sagen, im Gegenteil. Jetzt haben wir diese Scheiße mit diesem Blogsystem überwunden. Das war doch eine riesengroße Chance, war oder ist, eine Riesenchance zu sagen, wir versuchen jetzt Weltpolitik zu machen, nicht mehr auf der Grundlage von Feindbildern, sondern wir versuchen eine andere Art zu finden, unsere Interessen miteinander in Einklang zu bringen. Und es hat dann zum Gegenteil geführt. Also bei den Leuten. Auf einmal fühlen die sich bedrohter als je zuvor. Du kannst ja auch nachweisen, die Kriminalität in Deutschland geht zurück. Alle Statistiken sagen, dass auch unser Land jetzt im kleinen Bereich Mord, Totschlag, Vergewaltigung, die Kapitalverbrechen, die gehen zurück. Jahr für Jahr sind es weniger. Wenn du Umfragen anschaust, was die Leute denken, die denken, es wird schlimmer, während es in Wahrheit aber weniger wird. Also als hätte das quasi so ein antiprofessioneller Zusammenhang.
Mir erscheint das schon manchmal so ein Dogma zu sein, dass man das einfach zu glauben hat. Also dass das eigentlich so ein gegebenes Gesetz ist, es wird immer schlimmer.
Wir müssen die Sachen schon beim Namen nennen. Deutschland ist der drittgrößte Waffenexporteur der Welt. Es sind Milliarden, die daran hängen. Wenn man jetzt sagt, ich stimme euch völlig zu, wenn man darauf hinweist, die Welt ist sicherer geworden, wir brauchen die meisten dieser Waffen überhaupt nicht. Was machen dann diese ganzen riesigen Firmen, die sich ernähren? Erstens kommt dann sofort das Geschrei Arbeitsplätze. Zweitens kommt das Geschrei irgendwie Deutschland hängt von der Exportwirtschaft ab. Und drittens müsste man eigentlich ehrlich zugeben, dass trotz, obwohl viele, viele Leute in diesem Land freiheitlich und friedlich eingestellt sind und das auch immer wieder kundtun, es zum Beispiel so gut wie gar keinen Protest dagegen gibt, dass Deutschland eine Reihe von völlig inhuman grauenvollen Waffen nicht nur herstellt, sondern sie fast überall weltweit exportiert. Da sind handfeste, riesige wirtschaftliche Interessen, die natürlich durch die Lobby-Arbeit dann auch politisch wirksam werden.
Das haben die schon die ganzen letzten Jahrzehnte gemacht. Da ist immer noch nicht sozusagen der Finger auf der Wunde, warum sind die Leute jetzt so eingeschüchtert?
Vor 1989 musstest du ja keine anderen Feindbilder und keine anderen Verunsicherungen produzieren, weil es jedem klar war, es gibt den anderen Block. Also es hängt glaube ich schon damit zusammen.
Das glaube ich auch, aber irgendwie trotzdem, also es steht immer noch mit einer gewissen Ratlosigkeit davor, warum das so ist, weil der Zusammenhang zwischen immer besseren und sichereren Lebensbedingungen und immer größerer Angst, der ist fatal. Also es bezieht sich ja auch nicht nur auf Terrorismus. Es ist ja inzwischen so, dass keine Jahreszeit mehr vorbeigehen kann, ohne dass es der Jahrhundertsommer, der Katastrophenwinter oder der Untergangsfrühling oder irgendwie der Grippeherbst oder sowas ist. Also noch nicht mal das Wetter kann einfach nur als Regen, Hagel und Schnee bezeichnet werden, sondern es muss alles mit der Rhetorik einer Naturkatastrophe überlegt werden. Ja, das sind alles, wir reden sowieso nur, also wir reden wahrscheinlich die ganze Zeit über mediale Phänomene.
Genau, dann kommen wir doch auch mal zu diesen medialen Phänomenen. Ich meine, wenn man jetzt sagt, es gibt so ein gesellschaftliches Bewusstsein, dann ist das natürlich primär von den Medien geprägt, zumindest noch.
Geprägt, gespiegelt, man weiß es nicht.
Ja, oder eben vielleicht auch verursacht. Das wäre jetzt quasi meine nächste Frage, wie ihr das so seht, was ihr da herausgefunden habt. In gewisser Hinsicht jetzt mit dem Aufkommen des Internets hat es jetzt eine neue Dimension. Ich denke, dass es jetzt auch eine Diskussionskultur gibt, dass die Gesellschaft sich eben auch tatsächlich mal selber miteinander unterhält, ohne Medien oder selber das Medium darstellt, wie man auch mal das sehen möchte. Das mag jetzt auch noch mal einen Wandel herbeiführen oder auch nicht. Trotzdem sind wir schon eben noch stark geprägt zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt, denke ich mal, auch was die sogenannte vierte Macht im Staate, wie sie beweihräuchernd genannt wird, was sie für eine Rolle spielt. Warum ist denn das so? Warum ist denn Jahrhundertsommer? Warum ist denn immer so dieses Extrem da? Ist das jetzt wirklich nur dieser kapitalistische Hintergrund mit, wir müssen das jetzt verkaufen? Oder gibt es da auch irgendwie einen Wahn?
Also dass es darum geht, Dinge zu verkaufen, glaube ich, absolut. Und vielleicht liegt der Grund dafür, dass sich das so krass verstärkt hat. Also diese Skandalbesessenheit, diese Zwang, egal was passiert. Und wenn es, das kleinste Ereignis, wenn es das Wetter ist, ist sofort hochzustillisieren zu einer Katastrophe. Vielleicht hängt das gerade damit zusammen, dass die Medien die Gegenwart dieses neuen Mediums Internet spüren. Die wissen eben, dass die Aufmerksamkeit der Bürger und ihr Informationsbedürfnis und ihr Diskursbedürfnis sich anfängt, dezentraler und außerhalb der Kontrolle zu organisieren und zu befriedigen. Und vielleicht ist es quasi wie ein Kind, das immer lauter schreit, weil es Aufmerksamkeit will und immer krasser wird, wenn es das Gefühl hat, man wendet sich von ihm ab.
Also das Internet ist doch an einem schuld.
Nicht schuld, also im Gegenteil. In dem Fall würde ich ja sagen, das wäre ja quasi eine hoffnungsvolle These. Dann würde ich sagen, das sind die letzten Zuckungen eines zu Tode verwundeten Löwen, der jetzt immer noch Jahrhundertsommer schreit, so lange bis sich alle abwenden und sagen, ey Leute, wir nehmen euch echt nicht mehr ernst. Auch die sogenannten seriösen Medien, wir nehmen euch nicht mehr ernst. Das ist nicht die Form von Journalismus, die den Titel Vierte Gewalt und Kontrolleinstanz im Staate verdient.
Könnte das mit den Kollegen nicht sogar genauso laufen? Ich meine, wenn man jetzt hier durch die Straßen läuft, die ersten Wahlparkarte lächeln einen an, mit denselben Sätzen, die man auch schon vor 10 und 20 Jahren gelesen hat. Also, ich weiß nicht, Leistung muss sich wieder lohnen, kam jetzt irgendwie nicht so neu vor.
Nee, ich kenne hier auch schon den Satz.
Arbeit, Arbeit, Arbeit oder so habe ich auch schon in allen Formen und Farben irgendwo schon mal gesehen.
Weil ein Satz, Leistung muss sich wieder lohnen, ist sowas von zynisch, dass man dem Herrn, der das sagt, einfach eigentlich in die Fresse hauen müsste. Weil wenn er mal auf den Bau geht, wo, Entschuldigung, alt andere Migranten wie ich wirklich eine unglaublich harte Arbeit, 12 Stunden für drei, teilweise drei, dreieinhalb, vier Euro die Stunde. Also, ich möchte mal sehen, wie Herr Westerwelle die Arbeit mal auch nur einen Tag macht und ob er dann sagt, Leistung muss sich lohnen. Also, das sind solche Sätze, wo ich einen Hals kriege, weil sie natürlich von einer Verachtung gegenüber den normalen Menschen zeugen. Es ist wirklich so diese Kaste der Politiker, die, glaube ich, auch gar nicht wissen, wie sie die Menschen nehmen. Es ist wirklich so von oben errabt. Das sind so geradezu prophetische Sätze, die eine Mantraqualität haben sollen. Da sollen die Leute alle so, oh ja, ohm, ohm, ohm sagen, Leistung muss sich wieder lohnen. Das ist wahrscheinlich auch von einer Werbeagentur richtig so gestylt. Hat ja eine sehr schöne Silbenabfolge. Aber mit den Realitäten hat das überhaupt nichts zu tun. Im Gegenteil, die meisten Arbeitsplätze, die neu geschaffen werden, sind Arbeitsplätze, die ganz miserabel bezahlt werden und die ganz, ganz harte Arbeit bedingen. Und die lohnt sich überhaupt nicht im Sinne von menschenwürdiges Auskommen.
Ein anderes Wahlplakat sagt Sicherheit und Freiheit. Was geht euch denn dadurch?
Das habe ich gar nicht gesehen.
Es steht einfach nur Sicherheit und Freiheit und das war's?
Ja, mit so einem einleitenden Satz, das es ist, wie es nicht anders sein konnte, halt ein CDU-Wahlplakat mit Herrn Schäuble drauf.
Stand da nicht irgendwie sogar so etwas wie sicher leben? Ist das nicht der Spruch auch? Den habe ich glaube ich auch auf dem Wahlplakat von der CDU gesehen.
Das kann ich nicht ausschließen.
Sicherheit und Freiheit, einfach so?
Also er will quasi sagen, wir stehen für beides. Wir stehen für Sicherheit und für Freiheit.
Sicherheit, Freiheit und 500 Gramm Schweinekotelett am Tag.
Ja, ich meine, ist doch schön einfach die Welt, oder? Also ich meine, dann ist doch alles klar. Wir wählen CDU und alles wird gut.
Ja, Schäuble vertritt ja auch öfter mal in Interviews so. Der sagt ja dann immer so, Sicherheit und Freiheit muss kein Widerspruch sein. Damit geht es dann schon mal los. Und dann macht er so ein Kausalitätsverhältnis, wenn ich das richtig im Kopf habe, dann sagt er quasi, Freiheit ist nur auf Grundlage von Sicherheit möglich. Nicht etwa umgekehrt, sondern er sagt, die Bedingung der Freiheit ist die Sicherheit. Und das ist, glaube ich, was dann auch auf solchen Wahlsprüchen inne wohnt. Das ist eben ein Weltbild, das behauptet, frei ist der Bürger, der vom Staat so gepempert wird, dass er sich vorher nichts mehr fürchten muss. Aber damit ist nicht gemeint soziale Absicherung, sondern damit ist eben gemeint Kontrolle.
Und wie siehst du das?
Nicht so, ich sehe es umgekehrt. Also ich finde, man kann, selbst wenn man jetzt kein Historiker ist, kein Soziologe, in keiner Weise ein Experte, einfach ein bisschen zurückgucken in die Geschichte oder man guckt vielleicht auch ein bisschen ins Ausland, wie Staaten organisiert sind zum Teil. Und man guckt sich mal so eine Diktatur an. Die müsste dann ja nach der These von Schäuble und vielen anderen eine ganz geringe Kriminalitätsrate haben und wahnsinnig sicher und freiheitlich sein. Weil da gibt es ja dann sozusagen das Höchstmaß an Kontrolle und das müsste ja dann nach dieser These dazu führen, dass die Leute sich frei fühlen und außerdem das Lebensrisiko in jeder Hinsicht minimiert wird. Man sieht empirisch, das stimmt nicht. Es ist umgekehrt. Es stimmt gar nicht. Also die Staaten sind sicher.
Also Saudi-Arabien ist ein wunderbares Beispiel. Die sind super durchkontrolliert. Also schlimmer geht es gar nicht.
Makronische Strafen.
Makronische Strafen, völlige Kontrolle, die Kriminalität stark kontinuierlich.
Also der Zusammenhang ist einfach falsch, weil was aus meiner Sicht einen Staat überhaupt nur sicher machen kann, ich benutze das Wort schon immer gedanklich nur noch in Anführungszeichen, ist etwas, was sich aus einer freiwilligen Haltung der Bürger ergibt. Also du kannst diese Sicherheit, dies da geht nicht erzwingend durch Kontrolle oder Strafandrohungen, sondern diese Sicherheit ergibt sich dann, wenn eine möglichst große Menge von Menschen innerhalb der Gesellschaft beschließt, wir fahren alle miteinander vernünftigerweise am besten, wenn wir uns an ein paar Regeln halten und uns gegenseitig nicht so arg auf die Füße treten, so weit möglich. Wenn sich dieser Geist durchsetzt und breit macht, dann wird es kontinuierlich sicherer. Und das ist aber nichts, was erzwungen wird, sondern das ergibt sich eben gerade daraus, dass man den Leuten eine persönliche Freiheit einräumt und ihnen so weit irgendwie beibringt, sie verantwortungsbewusst zu gebrauchen. Und das funktioniert aber nicht, indem man sie wie kleine Kinder behandelt. Weil das steckt ja auch hinter dieser Politik oder hinter dieser ganzen Mentalität. Das ist im Grunde eine Infantilisierung. Die Leute werden behandelt wie kleine Kinder, denen du ständig sagen musst, übrigens rauchen schadet deiner Lunge. Wenn du über die Straße gehst, brauchen wir eine Videokamera, weil du bist so blöd. Wir müssen dich eigentlich die ganze Zeit dabei beobachten. Und davor müssen wir die schützen, da ist eine Gefahr, das müssen wir gleich verbieten. Und hier kommt wenigstens ein fetter Warnhinweis drauf. Also es ist ein riesiger Entmündigungsprozess und der führt erfahrungsgemäß empirisch nicht zu einer sicheren Gesellschaft. Von daher ist das, was Schäuble da immer so leichten Volltönen sagt, glaube ich, einfach falsch.
Das sind halt lauter alte Hopsianer, die sind völlig besessen von diesem Gedanken, dass zwei Menschen, wenn sie irgendwie ohne Reglements nebeneinander leben müssen, sich gegenseitig zerfleischen.
Und zwar sofort. Also wir drei müssten jetzt eigentlich sofort übereinander herfallen, es sei denn, Tim hat Überwachungskameras in seiner Wohnung.
Nein, deswegen hat Tim diesen riesigen Schreibtisch der Distanzschaft und er hat lauter dubiose Sachen hier. Wir wissen nicht, ob das nicht Waffen sind oder so. Und deswegen sind wir jetzt eingeschüchtert und überrauben ihn nicht.
Das ist alles nur, um euch zu verwirren. Also mir hat ein anderer Politiker, ich sage jetzt mal den Namen nicht, aber neulich so bei so einem Vorfeld zu einer Diskussion auch so den Satz fallen gelassen, man muss die Leute ja auch vor sich selbst beschützen.
Ah ja, da gehen mir die Nackenhaare so richtig schön nach oben.
Also man könnte ja eigentlich nur definieren, was Freiheit bedeutet, wir können ja ein Spiel spielen. Was in einem Satz definiert, was bedeutet Freiheit für die verschiedenen Parteien. Und es gibt diesen schönen alten Spruch, für die FPD bedeutet Freiheit, jeder Bundesbürger hat die Freiheit, einen Porsche zu fahren. Und für die CDU könnte man hinzufügen, jeder Bürger hat die Freiheit, die Gesetze einzuhalten. Und so könnte man sozusagen durchgehen, es ist ja immer irgendwelche Freiheitsbegriffe, die von irgendwelchen relativ strengen, ideologischen Positionen ausgehen. Und eigentlich, das finde ich ja das Erschreckende, und deswegen kriegt man ja entweder einen Lachanfall oder einen Wutanfall, wenn man diese ganzen Spüche und Kampagnen und Plakate sieht, weil sie nach meinem Dafürhalten überhaupt kein wirkliches Freiheitsverständnis haben. Das sind irgendwelche invaliden Freiheitsgedanken, die da totgeboren irgendwie in die Öffentlichkeit geworfen werden.
Und generell steht Freiheit momentan sowieso nicht hoch im Kurs. Also als sexy Wahlspruch eignet sich das kaum. Es wird schon wirklich viel mehr mit Sicherheit geworden in allen Bereichen. Das scheint besser zu ziehen. Was wieder matcht mit diesem Gefühl, dass die Leute einfach Angst haben und das auch ganz gern gebrauchen können zur Zeit, dass jemand sagt, die beschützen euch.
Ja, aber die Leute haben nicht Angst. Vielleicht könnt ihr mir eine Sache erklären. Die Leute fahren... Ne, aber erklär mal eine Sache. Ich habe ja kein Auto. Und ich fahre ja wirklich alle fünf Jahre mal, wenn ich einen Mietwagen nehmen muss, weil es unbedingt dringend notwendig ist. Und das war neulich der Fall. Die rasen ja auf der Autobahn. Das ist ja phänomenal. Ich bin nur zwei Stunden gefahren. Ich habe mindestens drei schreckliche Fast-Unfälle gesehen. Völlig unnötig, weil jemand da irgendwie mit 180, 190 Haarschaf überholen muss. Wo ist da die Angst? Aber davor haben die nicht Angst.
Das heißt, da wird die Freiheit gelebt.
Genau, da wird die Freiheit gelebt. Das heißt, was wir eigentlich erleben, ist, dass die Leute da, wo sie Angst haben sollten, keine haben. Und da, wo sie keine haben sollten, Angst haben. Das heißt eigentlich eine völlig unnatürliche Reaktion. Der Mensch ist nicht mehr lebensfähig, weil er Angst ist ja eigentlich etwas Instinktives, was wir benötigen, um uns zu schützen. Der Mensch kann sich nicht schützen, weil er aufgrund dieser ganzen Entwicklung und dieser ganzen Manipulation nicht mehr natürliche Ängste hat. Sondern er hat nur noch künstliche, artificielle Ängste. Und die helfen ihm offensichtlich überhaupt nicht. Die beraten ihn im Gegenteil ganz schlecht.
Zumindest ist er dann nicht in der Lage, frei politisch zu denken, wenn er nur ins Boxhorn gejagt ist.
Genau.
Aber jetzt muss ich ja nochmal wieder ein bisschen zurückkommen zu diesem eigentlichen Angst-Ding. Du hast gesagt, sie haben jetzt vor allem Angst. Es ist ein bisschen schwer zu greifen, jetzt vor allem Angst zu haben.
Aber ich kann Sachen aufzählen.
Ja, mach mal.
Okay. Die haben totale Angst vor Jobverlust, wenn sie einen Job haben und keinen Job zu kriegen, wenn sie noch Schüler sind. Also ich bin oft ab und zu in Gymnasien und mache da Lesungen aus den Büchern und rede dann auch mit den Leuten, die mit zarten 16, 17 Jahren, wo man sich eigentlich überlegen sollte, wo man seinen nächsten Joint kauft, denken die darüber nach, ob sie einen Job kriegen später oder ob sie aus der Gesellschaft rausfallen und als Versager und Ausgestoßene verrecken. Das ist die Angst. Die ist in jeder Hinsicht unrealistisch, aber die sind wie kleine Maschinen. Die denken nicht, wir wollen ein bisschen Spaß haben, unsere Persönlichkeit entwickeln und mal so rein grooven.
Die sind sicherlich nicht so.
Das ist total unrealistisch. Ich bin ja an Gymnasien. Das sind Leute aus mindestens mittelschicht Elternhäusern, die zu 99% ihr Abitur schaffen. Das ist so an einem Gymnasium heutzutage. Und diese 99% gehen auch fast geschlossen studieren. Und alle diese Akademiker oder ein Großteil der Akademiker kriegt auch einen Job. Also das sind nicht die Leute, die davor Angst haben müssen, keinen Job zu bekommen. Das ist zumindest total übertrieben. Und selbst wenn sie keinen kriegen, ist es ja nicht so, dass man dann gleich verreckt. Also die haben eine existenzielle, wirklich tief in den Knochen sitzende Angst, die sie ihr Leben auf bestimmte Art und Weise gestalten lässt. Und da krieg ich dann wiederum Angst, wenn ich die sehe.
Aber nur eine kleine Klammer zu deiner Frage, selbst wenn die reell wäre, die Angst. Das Entscheidende ist ja, dass die überhaupt mit 17 und so was denken. Das ist mir auch aufgefallen. Weil mit 17 habe ich überhaupt nicht angetan. Und vor allem noch eine Kleinigkeit, was ich so lustig finde, die fragen mich bei solchen Gymnasiallesungen immer. Das ist immer einer, der mich fragt, wie viel verdient man als Autor?
Mindestens einer, immer.
Ich bin jedes Mal geschockt.
Kann man davon leben?
Ich glaube, dass ich bis Mitte 20 überhaupt nicht darüber nachgedacht habe, wovon werde ich leben.
Die Frage kenne ich natürlich auch.
Stellst du dich dir selber hier zerfallen? Tim, wovon lebst du eigentlich?
Ja, das Heerscharen von Leuten, die sich die Kopf darüber zerfallen.
Das interessiert ihr beiden.
Da muss ich sagen, da bin ich halt auch wirklich jetzt komplett anders. Deswegen frage ich ja auch nochmal doppelt doof, weil ich mir es persönlich, ich weiß nicht warum, aber ich habe es mir halt von vornherein mich eigentlich zum Optimismus gezwungen, um mich nicht, also das trieb auch wirklich Blüten, weil zum Beispiel war es für mich einfach überhaupt nicht denkbar, Versicherungen abzuschließen, weil das so für mich das Eingeständnis einer Angst gewesen wäre in gewisser Hinsicht und ich immer davon ausgegangen bin, es geht schon irgendwie. Heute sehe ich das auch differenzierter. Es gibt durchaus Versicherungen, die mögen sinnvoll sein, aber es gibt auch genug, die definitiv nicht sinnvoll sind. Bloß ich wollte mich glaube ich einfach fernhalten von dieser Angst, die damit verbunden ist, oder das auch nur zugeben, dass ich diese Angst habe. Trotzdem frage ich mich, warum ist es denn jetzt anders bei dieser Generation? Wo kommt die Angst her?
Ich weiß nicht, wo die herkommt. Wahrscheinlich ist es so, dass denke ich manchmal, es gibt sozusagen ein festes Quantum an Angst, was im einzelnen Menschen drin ist und was deswegen auch gesellschaftlich da ist. Das ist wie so eine wabernde, aber relativ konstante Größe. Der Mensch hat einfach Angst. Die Frage ist sozusagen nur, wovor und wie kanalisiert sich das? Und ich habe das früher genauso empfunden, wie du das jetzt auch geschildert hast. Diese Sorte von Angst, also so eine Existenzangst, das war uncool, das war irgendwie auch spießig. So wolltest du ja gar nicht sein.
Das kann sein, ja.
Also dir wurde quasi von deiner, das sind so blöde Begriffe, aber ich sage es jetzt mal trotzdem, deine Identität oder deine Identifikation, war eigentlich in die Welt zu gehen und erst mal zu sagen, also was waren denn so unsere Ideen? Viel rumreisen war wichtig, sich was angucken, so offen sein, Sachen irgendwie auch Spaß haben, das war auch ein Wert oder man konnte sich darunter was Positives vorstellen und wer hier sich jetzt hingesetzt hätte und gesagt hätte, ne also ich habe echt viel zu viel Angst, um Spaß zu haben oder um zu reisen, ich muss eigentlich dauernd darüber nachdenken, ob ich einen Job kriege und ob ich jetzt lieber BWL oder Medizin studiere, dann hättest du gesagt, so ja Baby, also du wärst nicht gut angekommen mit dieser Haltung und ich glaube, das hat sich einfach geändert. Wenn wir jetzt im Gymnasium wären, mit der Haltung von damals, dann wären diese Denke uncool. Dann würden die sagen, was ist das denn für ein Fantast, wie unrealistisch ist der denn die Verantwortung? Ja, was für ein Hippie hier. Die planen mit 16 ihre BWL-Karrieren. Mir haben Eltern gesagt, dass sie zu Hause ihren Kindern dauernd sagen, Mädel oder Junge, jetzt entspann dich doch mal ein bisschen, willst du nicht mal auf eine Party oder irgendwie ein bisschen was Schönes machen? Weil die selber das gruselig finden, dass die wie so kleine Maschinen dauernd an ihrem CV und ihrer Karriere im Voraus schon umplanen.
Also ein Freund von mir musste seine Tochter monatelang überreden, gerade zu zwingen, dass sie nach der Mabitur eine Weltreise macht.
Weil die wollte sofort anfangen zu studieren, um früh fertig zu sein und gleich in den Jets zu gehen. Wahnsinn, ist der Wahnsinn.
Aber es ist natürlich Ausdruck eines gesamtgesellschaftlichen Phänomens, das finde ich ganz offenkundig ist, nämlich dass wir eine Verspießerung erleben. Wir sind in einem Biedermeier-Zeitalter und das beeinflusst natürlich die jungen Menschen besonders, weil sie das ja aufsaugen, sie erleben es ja überall.
Wir sind in einem Biedermeier-Zeitalter?
Ja, also für mein Empfinden. Also sozusagen ein Neo-Biedermeier natürlich.
Neo, natürlich. Neo-Biedermeier ist ein schönes Wort. Und das, obwohl wir jetzt hier Cyberspace und alles am Start haben?
Ja, leider Gottes.
Das ist die Subversion, die gibt es immer im Biedermeier.
Es gibt ja auch im Biedermeier gab es ja, ich meine...
Gab es technischen Fortschritten?
Nee, nee, gab es ja auch Revolte. Also Revolte gibt es ja immer in irgendwelchen Formen. Nur die Frage ist...
Die Mehrheitsgesellschaft des Biedermeier, das wird es sein.
Die Mehrheitsgesellschaft. Schulen ist ein gutes Beispiel. Man merkt das aber auch, das erwähnen wir auch in unserem Buch, man merkt das, wenn man sich anguckt, was für Filme werden gedreht, was für Bücher. Es sind ganz, ganz viele, auch in der Unterhaltungsindustrie, ganz, ganz viele Sachen, die sozusagen das altertümlich gesprochen, das Anzienregime verherrlichen. Das ist irgendwie bestimmte Formen des Lebens, bestimmte aristokratische Formen sind schick. Bestimmte Weisen, sich sozusagen zu kleiden, bestimmte moralische Vorstellungen. Es gibt jetzt eine ganze Bewegung, dass man irgendwie, bevor man heiratet, keinen Sex haben soll und so weiter und so fort. Also man könnte wirklich stundenlang Beispiele aufzeigen. Wo immer man hinguckt, merkt man diese Verspießerung. Deswegen nenne ich das Neo-Biedermeier. Und ich kann mir vorstellen, dass ein junger Mensch, der nicht jetzt einen ganz, ganz eigenen Charakter hat, der nicht wirklich sehr stark beseelt ist von seiner persönlichen Haltung zur Welt, dass davon natürlich sehr stark beeinflusst wird. Und das sind die meisten Jungen.
Gut, dann nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal so an, auch wenn wir es nicht näher belegen können. Es gibt so eine Angst. Und wie du schon meintest, man hat eigentlich immer Angst vor beidem. Das ist jetzt eigentlich interessant. Also, meinst du, habe ich einen Job, habe ich Angst, den zu verlieren, habe ich keinen, habe ich Angst, keinen zu bekommen? Hast du noch andere Beispiele von sich gegenseitig antreibenden Ängsten?
Ob sich es gegenseitig antreibt, müssen wir gleich noch analysieren. Aber das nächste, wo Leute auf einmal Angst haben, die ganze Zeit sind halt Gesundheit, also Krankheiten auf einmal. Das ist auch schon in einem Alter. Ein Beispiel. Davor war Vogelgruppe, dann war BSE, dann war irgendwie. Und dann aber auch privat. Also diese Gesellschaft ist unglaublich hypochondrisch geworden. Also ständig rennen, also alle müssen dauernd irgendeinen Sport machen, weil sie sonst ja nicht gesund sind oder sie sind nicht fit genug. Und über Rauchen und Alkohol und was braucht man gar nicht reden, das liegt einfach auf der Hand. Also das hat sich in den letzten Jahren, das ist schon eine längere Entwicklung, wie alles, aber für mein Empfinden hat es sich in den letzten Jahren auch nochmal intensiviert und es greift auch jetzt immer stärker in den politischen Bereich. Das sind auch Ängste.
Kann das sein, dass es so ein Mangel an Solidarität ist, den man empfindet und dass deshalb diese Dinge auf einmal einem Angst machen? Ich meine, den Job verlieren und so, das war ja noch nie schön. Und keinen kriegen und so.
Auch krank sein ist nicht schön oder alt sein.
Aber das ist auch nichts Neues. Das haben sicherlich die Leute immer schon empfunden. Die Frage ist nur, was ist die Konsequenz dessen? Und ich glaube, was so ein bisschen hintergeht ist...
Warum muss der Staat jetzt irgendwie da sein?
Genau, man hat immer das Gefühl, oder ich hab zumindest das Gefühl, dass die Leute das Gefühl haben, dass sie dann in ein unglaubliches schwarzes Loch trudeln, in dem es nur noch bergab geht und das ist ganz furchtbar und das muss irgendwie verhindert werden. Vielleicht ist es einfach, das ist jetzt nur so eine Idee von mir, würde mich interessieren, was ihr meint, dass so eine Art, dass so diese gemeinschaftliche Solidarität nicht mehr so eine Rolle spielt, wo man sich vorher immer aufgefangen fühlte in so einem gesellschaftlichen Nest, dass das fehlt, ist das vielleicht der Grund? Die Ängste sind nicht neu, nur die Angst davor, dass es kein Netz gibt.
Also das glaube ich auch und der Grund, wieso ich das glaube, weil ich ja seit vielen Jahren immer wieder vergleiche, wie ist es in Orten wie z.B. Bombay in Indien, wo ich fast sechs Jahre gelebt habe, und wie ist es bei uns. Und es hat mich immer wieder fasziniert, dass die Leute dort 50-100 Mal sozial schlechter gestellt sind, aber diese Ängste nicht haben. Und eine der Erklärungen, die ich gefunden habe, ist tatsächlich, dass die meisten in irgendwelchen Solidargemeinschaften leben, dass sie wirklich größere Strukturen haben, dass sie wissen, jemand wird mich schon auffangen. Das ist natürlich nicht der einzige Grund. Anderer Grund ist, dass sie viel weniger Ansprüche haben, dass für die sozusagen das Überleben schon ausreicht, während bei uns jemand schon Angst geknallt hat, dass er sich denkt, er wird irgendwie nur noch...
Ich könnte meinen Mercedes mehr fahren.
Ich müsste meinen Mercedes verkaufen.
Das ist aber auch hart.
Ja, was ist das eigentlich? Was der Tim vor der Tür hier hat? Das ist ein 350er. Nee, ein Hummerpferd. Das darf aber niemand wissen. Aber insofern glaube ich, du hast recht. Das ist jetzt nichts Neues. Jeder von uns ist eine ganz starke Atomisierung in der Gesellschaft. Jeder hängt irgendwie vom Bildschirm.
Atomisierung?
Atomisierung, ja.
Aber das hat nichts mit Bildschirm zu tun.
Nein, nicht nur.
Das hat überhaupt gar nichts mit Bildschirm zu tun.
Doch, das hat glaube ich schon ein bisschen mit Fernsehen zu tun. Beim Fernsehgucken entstehen sozusagen artificielle Gemeinschaftsräume.
Weißt du, wie viel Fernsehen in Indien und in den dritten Weltländern geguckt wird?
Ja, aber weißt du, wie geguckt wird?
Da kommen wirklich 80 Leute zusammen. Romantisch ist das alle, weil es nur ein Fernseher gibt.
Und der Fernseher ist eigentlich sekundär, weil sie sich untereinander unterhalten, weil sie kommentieren, weil sie brüllen, weil sie kämpfen, weil sie lachen, sonst irgendwas. Da ist der Fernsehen sozusagen fast ein...
Brüllt wird ja hier auch viel vom Fernseher, glaube ich.
Wenn wirklich der Mensch alleine vom Fernseher...
Ist das bei euch so? Ach du hast auch keinen, hier sitzen schon drei Leute, die keinen haben.
Wow, das ist echt, drei Leute in einem Raum, die keinen Fernseher haben.
Fernseher ist total out, mega out.
Ich müsste jetzt richtig nachdenken. Ja, ich kenne auch Leute, die haben Fernseher.
Aber nicht mehr so viele.
Ich rede auch nicht gern mit denen. In meinem unmittelbaren Umfeld nimmt das wirklich rapide ab.
Fernsehen war gestern.
Du bist gerade echt nicht hip.
Ja, das stimmt. Also, was das Problem ist mit dieser...
Gut, wieso Atomisierung? Was hast du für Erklärungen, wenn es überhaupt nicht an Bildschirmen liegt?
Ja, also genau, ich versuche es mal mit einem anderen Erklärungsansatz, der für mich diese Sache auch so traurig macht oder so gruselig. Weil immer, wenn jemand sagt, könnte es vielleicht daran liegen, dass alle Angst haben, weil wir keine Solidarität mehr haben, dann will ich als erstes immer schreien, nein, auf gar keinen Fall. Und das will ich deswegen, weil ich glaube, dass dieser Rückgang von Solidarität auf ein paar Sachen zurückzuführen ist, die ich gut finde. Und das ist der Abbau von religiösen Strukturen innerhalb der Gesellschaft, die auf eine bestimmte Form von Solidarität verpflichtet haben. Das ist der Abbau von familiären Zwängen, die in anderen Ländern ja auch nach wie vor sehr virulent sind. Wir können das inzwischen von außen romantisch sehen, dass es den sogenannten Familienzusammenhalt gibt, wo der Cousin selbst noch der drittweitst entferntesten Nichte hilft. Tatsächlich materiell durch Geld oder durch Unterkunft hilft, wenn ein Problem auftritt. Das sieht aus unserer Sicht jetzt schon wieder schön und romantisch und wünschenswert aus. Dass das bei uns aber nicht mehr so ist, ist, weil wir eine Emanzipation durchgeführt haben. Und wir wissen auch warum. Weil all diese Strukturen, egal ob religiös oder familiär, letztlich immer auch Unterdrückungsstrukturen waren, Machtstrukturen, wo wir gesagt haben, hier herrschen Ungerechtigkeiten, die wir nicht mehr wollen. Und die haben wir halt abgebaut. Und zwar ganz massiv nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg. Das ist in der zweiten Hälfte des 20. Jahrhunderts auf eine Spitze getrieben worden. Und jetzt haben wir diese atomisierte Gesellschaft. Was lernen wir jetzt denn daraus? Soll das jetzt quasi heißen als Antwort? Aufklärung war eine super Idee. So in der Theorie. Aber praktisch durchgeführt, wenn man sie quasi mehr oder minder an ihr Ziel bringt, müssen wir leider feststellen, dass sie dann dazu führt, dass die Leute so eine Angst kriegen, dass sie wieder nach dem starken Start schreien und das Ganze sozusagen im Kreis wieder von vorne anfängt. Das finde ich als Diagnose zwar irgendwie logisch, aber auch inakzeptabel. Das kann doch nicht das Ergebnis von 300 Jahren Anstrengung sein, die Leute irgendwie zu mündigen Bürgern zu erziehen und sie rauszulösen aus religiösen, familiären und sonstigen...
Ja, aber du konstruierst Dichotomien, die glaube ich so nicht existieren. Der aufklärerische Impetus war immer auch beseitigt, wenn du dir die großen Rebellionen anguckst, immer auch von einem ganz großen Solidaritätsgedanken.
Aber die haben nie erklärt, wie diese Solidarität am Leben gehalten werden soll. Immer nur über die Vernunft. Die haben gesagt, Solidarität ist vernünftig, das sehe ich auch so. Aber Solidarität funktioniert nur unter Zwang.
Nein, nein, das stimmt nicht. Also wenn du was wie Kropotkin liest, zum Beispiel nur mal einzunehmen der vielen Sozial-Otopisten, dann ist da ganz klar zwei Sachen. Das eine ist, es gibt Solidarität in der Natur. Das ist sozusagen ein grundsätzlicher, natürlicher Zustand, weil es dem Eigenwohl dient. Also wie, ich war ja in der Antarktis letztes Jahr und das hat mich wirklich sehr beeindruckt, auch persönlich zu sehen, wie die Pinguine wirklich, weil es so unglaublich kalt ist, sich ständig...
Sich zusammenballen.
Ja, nicht nur sich zusammenballen, sondern ständig die Position wechseln. Das heißt, jeder der draußen ist, im eiskalten Wind ausgesetzt, geht dann nach einigen Minuten nach innen und die von innen gehen nach außen. Und das funktioniert ständig wie so ein perfektes System. So Beispiel gibt es ja sehr, sehr viele in der Natur. Es gibt sozusagen einen natürlichen Solidaritätsgewerbenden. Und das zweite ist, das ist auch ganz, ganz klar an das Herz appelliert. Das sagt, das ist sozusagen das, was uns zum Menschen macht, diese Möglichkeit der Empathie, des Mitleidens mit unseren Mitmenschen. Und deswegen, dass wir die Probleme, die Sorgen, die Leiden der Mitmenschen als unsere aufnehmen. Das war bei vielen dieser, dieser für mich großen aufklärerischen Denker, war das ein Zentralmoment.
Absolut. Ich sehe das ja auch alles so. Nur realisiert sich das nicht in der praktischen Situation, wenn dahinter nicht was steht. Die Leute helfen einander unter, nur unter ganz bestimmten Bedingungen. Ich meine jetzt konkret. Also indem sie wirklich, was zum Beispiel von ihrem sauber verdienten Geld nehmen und sagen, das schenke ich jetzt dir, weil du es brauchst. Eine Bedingung unter der das passiert ist Familie. Man selber ist auch so. Also wem gebe ich Geld? Wem habe ich in meinem Leben schon Geld geschenkt? Das waren größere oder für mich größere Beträge. Das waren Familienmitglieder, weil es noch so ein Gefühl von familiärer Solidarität, Reste davon irgendwie gibt. Das funktioniert. Dann funktioniert religiöse Solidarität, karitative Sachen, weil Gott sagt, du sollst deinen Nächsten lieben und so. Das kann ich nur in der Theorie. Davon bin ich selber relativ frei. Oder im Angesicht der Katastrophe. Oderbruch, Tornado, was auch immer. Wenn es richtig rumst und rauscht, sei es nur in unserem bescheidenen deutschen Rahmen. Wir hatten das mal in Leipzig, so ein Sturm. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wie der hieß. Kyrill oder so. Der hat so ein paar Bäume umgeworfen in der Straße, ein paar Autos waren kaputt. Die Leute haben sich für einen Tag lang geliebt. Die standen auf der Straße, die waren so glücklich miteinander. Die waren auf einmal eine Gruppe und wir, die haben sich gegenseitig geholfen, ihre Autos unter dem Baum vorzuholen. Da war ein großes Herzen im Kollektiv. Zwei Tage später, wenn die Bäume wieder stehen und alles wieder bestens ist, halten die sich nicht mal gegenseitig die Tür auf, wenn der andere kommt, sondern knallen die dem vor die Nase. Und das kann man beobachten.
Das bestätigt doch das, was ich gesagt habe, dass es in Bombay gibt es einen Dauer. Diesen Dauerzustand, den du gerade bestätigt hast, ist dauerhaft und deswegen müssen die Leute solidarisch darauf reagieren.
Aber es ist schwer, dieses Ergebnis zu akzeptieren. Das heißt, uns geht es zu gut.
Es geht uns ja in einem gewissen Sinne zu gut, weil wir tatsächlich viel zu kommerziell sind, viel zu materialistisch. Das glaube ich schon.
Jetzt sind wir ja schon wieder so bei dem Bild des Frosches, das werdet ihr ja sicherlich kennen, gerade was Überwachungsstaat usw. betrifft, wird das ja immer wieder ganz gerne herangezogen. Nicht wahr? So, die Katastrophe, die alle aufweckt, so, wenn der Frosch halt ins Halte-Wass-Geworfen wird und so.
Also, nicht vorlesen.
Das kennt ja auch jeder. Ich halte es jetzt nicht aus dem Buch, das ist ja eine gängige Sache, da gab es ja auch schon schicke Animationen, was nicht alles. Aber wo du das jetzt gerade sagst, es kann ja sein, weil man kann jetzt dieses Angstding und dieses vielleicht liegt es an der Solidarität, das war jetzt hier auch zunächst einmal auch nur eine These, dass das so die Ursache ist, dass diese Ängste so überhand nehmen. Ich sehe das jetzt einfach so aus dem Gespräch heraus, wie wir es bisher beschrieben haben. Die Ängste waren vielleicht schon immer da, aber jetzt haben sie auf einmal eine andere Bedeutung. Warum haben sie diese Bedeutung? Weil sich der gesellschaftliche Rahmen ändert und der Rahmen ändert sich unter anderem eben in dieser, ja, von liberalen Geistern doch eher positiv gesehenen Änderung im Sinne von, es hängt jetzt weniger von so vorgegebenen Strukturen ab, ja, die Familie hat nicht mehr so starke Dogmen, ich kann mich freier entfalten an der Stelle. Ja, und durch diese Freiheit kriegt man auf einmal Schiss, genau, man steht auf einmal alleine auf dem Feld da, hat das Gefühl so, oh Gott, wenn ich jetzt noch freier werde, dann, was passiert denn dann? Also, dass man sozusagen sich auch wieder so ein bisschen versucht, so behütet zu sehen. Jetzt könnte es natürlich sein, dass ja dieses Staatsmodell mit der wohlmeidenden Staat, der jetzt sich, wie hieß das in den USA, so schön, diese Compassionate Republicans, ja, das empfand ich immer schon ein bisschen als Widerspruch, aber nicht wahr? Dass man sich da eben so unter diese Fittiche gibt und dass eben der Staat auch so ein bisschen die Ersatzfamilie auf einmal so darstellt und dass man dann auch erwartet, da entsprechend beschützt zu werden. Könnte das?
Aber das kann es ja wohl nicht sein, oder? Also das kann nicht unser Ergebnis sein.
Da sind wir uns natürlich einig. Ich versuche ja auch erstmal nur so ein bisschen in die ich versuche das erstmal so psychologisch nachzuvollziehen.
Was ist los?
Was in dieser ganzen Debatte uns allen ja so schwer fällt, ist so, ich meine, wenn man hier bei dieser Hörerschaft, ich meine, da brauchen wir jetzt nicht anfangen, darüber zu diskutieren, zu sagen, dass wir mehr Freiheit haben wollen oder so. An dem Punkt sind wir alle schon lange. Die Frage ist nur, wie kriegen wir jetzt die anderen dazu, da auch mal entsprechend drüber nachzudenken? Und ihr kennt die Debatte, dieses Hab-nix-zu-verbergen Dingsbums. Das ist halt immer wieder da und jeder, der schon mal versucht hat, in seiner eigenen Familie Leute auf diese Thematik rüberzuziehen, sieht sich automatisch in dieser Situation, dass er irgendwie argumentativ nicht weiterkommt. Und ich glaube, viele Leute sind einfach auch total fassungslos darüber, dass das nicht ähnlich verfängt. Was braucht man denn da für ein Gehen, um das richtig zu empfinden?
Ja genau, das ist nämlich so komisch. Es gibt halt, also wir reden jetzt die ganze Zeit über die da draußen, also die halt so ängstlich sind und die das alle auch irgendwie nicht verstehen.
Die anderen.
Und wir drei sitzen hier und sagen von uns selber, wir haben diese Angst nicht. Kennen wir gar nicht. Wir haben keinen Fernseher. Ich meine, das mag irgendwie dazu beitragen, dass wir keine Angst haben. Weil wir sehen ja all diese Katastrophenmeldungen gar nicht.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall.
Ich glaube, ich bin der einzig lebende Mensch, der die Bilder vom 11. September bis heute nicht gesehen hat. Kann irgendjemand hier das von sich behaupten?
Wie die Bilder? Die Fernsehübertragung? Die hast du nicht gesehen?
Überhaupt irgendwelche Bilder. Wie diese Flugzeuge in diese Hochhäuser reinfahren.
Auch nicht in gedruckten Zeitschriften und so?
Doch, aber ich meine jetzt bewegt.
Wirklich?
Nee, hab ich nie gesehen. Hammer, oder? Ob ich da irgendwo... Krieg ich da irgendwo einen Award? Kann ich mich da irgendwo melden? Weil ich hab, in diesem Michael-Mur-Film kam es dann, ja? Ich weiß nicht, wer welches war. Aber der hat es dann schwarz gemacht. Da hab ich gedacht, okay, jetzt sehe ich gleich diese Bilder. Da sind sie. Und dann hat er das ausgeblendet und hat nur die Stimmen abgespielt. Wieder nicht gesehen. Welcher Film war denn das? Jetzt habe ich es total vergessen. Ach so, genau. Warum, das ist nämlich die Frage, die wir uns ja stellen müssen. Warum gibt es Leute, denen wir jetzt diagnostizieren, dass sie alle Angst haben und deswegen den Überwachungsstaat auch eigentlich ganz kuschelig finden? Und dann gibt es halt nicht nur uns drei, sondern es gibt ja so ein paar. Und man erkennt sich ja fast schon, ja? Also man redet zwei Sätze und dann merkt man sofort, dass irgendwie einer von uns, also der versteht, worum es uns geht oder was wir mit Freiheit meinen oder warum wir was gegen Kontrolle haben. Es gibt Leute, die es verstehen und es gibt Leute, die es nicht verstehen. Und das ist wie zwei verschiedene Spezies. Und es ist nicht einfach, jemanden aus der Ich-habe-nichts-zu-verbergen-Fraktion auf die andere Seite rüberzuziehen. Die hören dir zwar zu, die folgen auch eine Weile, denken, okay, das klingt logisch, was du sagst, aber sag den einmal, aber es steht doch ein Terroranschlag bevor, dann sind die sofort wieder in diesem Lager mit, ja, okay, und ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen und macht ihr mal schön. Und das finde ich daran so seltsam. Also warum gibt es Leute, und das ist die Mehrheit, die so reagieren, und dann gibt es ein paar, nach wie vor in der Minderheit, die anscheinend völlig immun sind gegen Panikmache und Fragmentisierung und Atomisierung und Lost in Space, weil es ja irgendwie keine kuschelige Familie mehr gibt oder so.
Aber jetzt habt ihr ja mit dem Buch schon ein bisschen versucht, die Diskussion aufzunehmen und die Leute da aufzurütteln. Was ist denn dann eure Argumentation?
Also wir müssen ja erstmal ehrlich was zugeben, was bisher überhaupt nicht zur Sprache kam, dass bei so einem Buch es natürlich nicht nur darum geht, ganz neue Argumente ins Spiel zu führen, sondern es geht in unserer medialen Gesellschaft natürlich auch darum, wer es wo sagt. Das heißt, es spielt einfach eine Rolle, dass zwei halbwegs bekannte Autoren das zusammen schreiben. Das heißt, man hat dann gleich eine gewisse Öffentlichkeit.
Wir sind keine Nerds.
Wir sind genau, wir kommen sozusagen aus dem Mainstream, in Anführungszeichen.
Wir kommen nicht aus dem Internet.
Genau, wir kommen nicht aus dem Internet.
Also solche strategischen, kann man ja ehrlich so geben, oder? Solche strategischen Überlegungen spielen eine Rolle, dass wir gesagt haben, dass Lesen mit Sicherheit zum Beispiel auch viele Fans unserer Romane, also ganz andere Bücher. Das heißt, da ist die Hoffnung, also ich habe jetzt zumindest, dass man auch einige Leute überzeugt, die überhaupt nicht aus der Szene kommen, die sozusagen ganz brav, bürgerlich, biedermeierlich so dahin leben. Und es waren ja auch die Reaktionen jetzt im Vorfeld, also Leute, die das Manuskript gelesen haben. Also ich habe jetzt von ein paar Freunden, auch vom Lektor gehört, dass er zum Beispiel die ganzen Payback- und Kundenkarten verweigert. Weil das tatsächlich also erwachsene, gebildete Leute sind, Doktoren sogar, pardon, also ist dann gar nicht abfällig gemeint, sondern Leute, von denen man meint, dass sie sich viele Gedanken machen, die überhaupt niemals darüber nachgedacht haben, was das bedeutet, so eine blöde Payback-Karte zu haben. Also insofern glaube ich schon, dass man ganz klassisch informieren, aufklären kann, glaube ich schon. Also natürlich nicht alle, natürlich nicht sofort, aber das ist sozusagen ein Schritt. Und deswegen war es uns auch so wichtig, bei dem Buch eigentlich jegliches Fachjargon und jegliche sozusagen Szenesprache zu vermeiden. Wir haben das eigentlich so geschrieben, dass wir uns gedacht haben, das muss ein 16-Jähriger, der so halbwegs lesen kann, verstehen können.
Ja, noch schlimmer, das muss jemand lesen können, der 65 ist und sich das Internet ausdruckt.
Na gut, aber was ist denn eure Argumentation? Also ich meine, das habe ich verstanden, den Ansatz und so. Aber glaubt ihr einen neuen Weg gefunden zu haben, zu argumentieren, dann würde mich der mal interessieren. Oder wie geht ihr da überhaupt ran? Also wir haben jetzt hier irgendwie Person X, und Person X sagt, ich habe nichts zu verbergen. Und der Staat muss für die Sicherheit sorgen. Und ich verzichte auch gerne ein bisschen auf meine Freiheit. Wir haben ja Ehe genug, uns geht es ja gut, so soll es bleiben, bla bla bla, Sicherheit und Freiheit. Das ist ja das, womit man sich irgendwie konfrontiert sieht.
Also ob die Argumentation neu ist, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Aber ich kann ja mal versuchen zu sagen... Genau. Also wir versuchen es aus verschiedenen Richtungen. Also wenn der Leser quasi ein Stier in der Arena wäre, dann schießen wir unsere Pfeile auf ihn aus verschiedenen Ecken. Also zum einen versuchen wir daran zu erinnern, was Grundrechte und was persönliche Freiheiten überhaupt sind, wie lange es diesen Gedanken schon gibt, warum es den gibt und wie hart er erforten worden ist. Also einfach mal nur daran erinnern, den Leuten das mal wieder bewusst machen, dass das keine Schönwetterveranstaltung ist und auch nichts Selbstverständliches. Also dass wir hier sitzen dürfen und nicht gleich von der Polizei herabgeholt werden, zum Beispiel, sondern dass das was Wertvolles ist, das muss man schützen. Das ist zum Beispiel eine so eine Sache. Dann versuchen wir zu erklären, ganz konkret anhand von Beispielen, was für Maßnahmen es jetzt vor allem seit dem 11. September gegeben hat, zum Punkt O, Kontrolle und Überwachungsstaat. Wir versuchen darzulegen, was uns die jeweiligen Erfinder dieser Gesetze gesagt haben, worum es da drin geht und was deren Ziel ist. Grob gesagt Terrorbekämpfung. Und wir versuchen zu analysieren, ob das stimmt. Dienen diese Gesetze tatsächlich der Terrorbekämpfung? Also sind die tauglich überhaupt zu dem angegebenen Zweck? Und finden an ganz vielen Stellen, da stimmt was nicht. Also der behauptete Zweck und das wie dieses Gesetz oder wie diese Maßnahme dann aussieht, das passt überhaupt nicht zusammen. Also da stimmt was in den Argumentationen nicht. Das versuchen wir offen zu legen, um den Leuten zu sagen, wenn die immer mit Terror winken und dann machen die ein Gesetz, dieser Zusammenhang steht auf tönernen Füßen. Also macht euch das mal klar, schaut genauer hin.
Nachdem die Rasterfahndung eingeführt wurde, gab es dann im Jahr danach die Auswertung von 8,3.
Wann war das?
Das ist schon eine Weile her. Also die wurde re-eingeführt nach dem 11. September.
Die neue, die nach dem 11.
Sagen wir 2003, sagen wir jetzt einfach mal.
Ich glaube 2003 wieder eingeführt und die Daten sind aus dem Jahr 2004, also aus dem ersten Jahr, in dem das vollständig wieder, in dem sie benutzt wurde, sodass man ein ganzes Jahr Statistik hat.
Um Schlepper zu finden.
So 8,3 Millionen Datensätze wurden ausgewertet. Das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen. Das ist mehr als ein Zehntel der Bevölkerung. Wenn man die ganzen Babys und Kreisen und so weiter rausrechnet, ist es wahrscheinlich...
Quasi jeder, beinahe schon.
Ja, ungefähr jeder Dritte der Bevölkerung. Es wurde ein einziges Ermittlungsverfahren eingeleitet und das wurde eingestellt. Das muss man sich echt vorstellen. Eine Maßnahme, die extrem in die Freiheitsrechte der Bürger eingreift, hat Null Erfolg. 0,0 Erfolg gehabt. Kein einziger terroristischer Schläfer.
Es kommt dann der Bürger X und sagt irgendwie, na ja, das hat mich ja jetzt nicht gekratzt, dass da mal einer meinen Datensatz abgeglichen hat und festgestellt hat, dass mit mir alles in Ordnung ist.
Darauf antworten wir gleich, aber weil es so unglaublich schön ist, das war der hessische Innenminister, scheinbar per Definition immer wieder sich lächerlich macht, der Vorgänger von dem jetzigen hat daraufhin dann gesagt, na ja, aber von der Rastafandung ging eine präventive Wirkung aufgrund der Medienberichterstattung aus und das islamistische Potenzial hat sie als Verfolgungsdruck empfunden. Und das ist einfach phänomenal, wie also sozusagen die Bewegung hessischer Dschihad irgendwo in Gießen und Kassel in den Kellerlöchern sich gar nicht mehr hinaus traut, weil es draußen die Rastafandung gibt.
Der Verfolgungsdruck nur so rappelt an den Toren.
Und seitdem gibt es in Hessen keine Gefahr mehr.
Und Deutschland ist wieder ein Stück sicherer geworden, oder?
Genau, das ist doch wirklich fantastisch. Also der hessische Innenminister hat sozusagen endlich ein Mittel gefunden, um die Selbstmörder zu erschrecken. Aber zu deiner Frage, die ja ein bisschen ernsthafter war, oder wollen wir nicht erstmal, willst du nicht weitermachen, die ganzen anderen Sachen, die wir in dem Buch machen?
Nein, jetzt hat Tim die Frage konkret gestellt, jetzt versuche ich, der Auftrag zu antworten. Also wir versuchen dann den Leuten zu sagen, es sind auch wieder verschiedene Ansätze, wie wir versuchen, sie zu kriegen. Also wir versuchen, ihnen klar zu machen, wie reagierst du eigentlich angenommen, du sitzt im Café und liest einfach nur Zeitungen oder du machst hier ein paar Notizen in deinem Heft und jetzt siehst du, wie sich einer von hinten über dich beugt und die ganze Zeit mitliest, was du da machst, wie reagierst du, was ist deine natürliche Reaktion. Jeder von uns, würde ich mal behaupten, wirklich ausnahmslos, dreht sich um und sagt ey hallo, spinnst du? Und wenn der Typ nicht weggeht, dann steht der auf und der wird sogar relativ schnell gewalttätig. Also ich würde mal behaupten, dass du mit dem Verhalten jemandem einfach nur über die Schulter zu gucken oder ihn überhaupt nur so anzustarren, die ganze Zeit nah ins Gesicht, ganz schnell eine körperliche Aggression hervorrufen kannst. Weil das natürliches Selbstschutzverhalten ist, zu sagen, es gibt hier einen Radius, nennen wir ihn Intimsphäre oder wie auch immer, wer den verletzt, ist respektlos. Und es geht nicht darum, ob ich in dem Moment etwas zu verbergen hatte, wo ich meine Zeitung gelesen habe oder wo der mir ins Gesicht start, sondern es geht um meine Würde, um meinen Stolz, um meine Integrität als Wesen. Weil diese Art der Annäherung, diese kontrollierende, beobachtende Annäherung ist sozusagen schon der Übergriff, unabhängig davon, was da jetzt inhaltlich gerade verhandelt wird.
Na ja gut, aber wenn die Datenbanken abgeklappert werden, dann stehe ich da ja nicht. Da guckt mir auch keiner ins Gesicht.
Aber die Frage wäre ja trotzdem, warum reagieren eben manche von uns überhaupt nicht darauf, wenn das sozusagen unbemerkt passiert, aber wenn es am Mann passiert, dann flippen sie vollkommen aus. Also wenn hier ein Begriff von... Ja, aber ich glaube, das ist als Argumentation gut bringen.
Wir haben ein anderes Beispiel, was von dir ist, was wirklich wunderschön ist, mit dem Handwerker.
Ja, genau.
Also der Handwerker zu Hause, ich habe ja gerade einen Wasserbruch und ich habe die Situation, man geht arbeiten, muss irgendwie zurück, wenn man was vergessen hat, wo findet man den Handwerker vor, der sitzt am eigenen Heimrechner und schaut so gerade durch, was man so alles geschrieben hat, was für Rechnungen man ausgestellt hat und so weiter.
Auch da körperliche Gewalt, beinahe schon.
Genau, also da würde jeder von uns wahrscheinlich ausflippen, aber spinnen sie was aus. Und es ist eigentlich nichts anderes, was der Staat macht und da braucht man jetzt wirklich nicht viel Fantasie um zu sehen, dass das wirklich eine Parallele ist. Also du schaust skeptisch.
Naja, weil ich einfach weiß, dass die Leute das eben einfach nicht so empfinden. Also es ist einfach die Vergleiche.
Doch, aber das wird einige überzeugen, das ist glaube ich ein gutes Argument. Weil die Leute müssen sich das bewusst machen, was das bedeutet. Die müssen erst mal bei sich selber merken, es ist nicht so, dass mich die Beobachtung nicht stört. Mich stört Beobachtung. Mein Problem ist sozusagen, mich stört staatliche Beobachtung nicht. Und dann fragen wir als nächstes ja, warum ist das so? Wie kann das sein, dass du das vom Handwerker nicht duldest? Beim Staat findest du es aber in Ordnung. Warum?
Was ist das für ein Staatsverständnis? Wir hatten das ja in der DDR, da liefen die Leute die ganze Zeit auf der Straße, da hat man sie gesehen. Und ich glaube, das hat die Leute auch wirklich gestört. Und jetzt sind wir aber in der Situation, dass wir ja natürlich in einer Technisierung leben. Und es ist halt eine Kamera. Und eine Kamera hat natürlich auch positive Konnotationen. Wir benutzen alle selber welche. Damit macht man die schönen Fotos von den Kindern und so. Ja, das kann ja nicht unbedingt was Böses sein. Alle laufen die ganze Zeit mit der Videokamera rum und filmen auch ihr eigenes Leben. Stellen es ja auch immer wieder ins Netz. Ihr prangert das ja auch so ein bisschen an. Kam auch glaube ich heute auf der Pressekonferenz nochmal so. Ihr benutzt kein Facebook und so. Da muss ich so ein bisschen in mich reingrenzen, weil ich halt auch sehe, es gibt auch neben dem Privatbedürfnis offensichtlich auch ein Öffentlichkeitsbedürfnis. Das ist denke ich mal ein Zeichen unserer Zeit, was jetzt eben durch diese technischen Mittel, die aufkommen, ob es jetzt nur die sozialen Netzwerke sind, werden wir sicherlich noch ganz andere Ausprägungen erleben, aber man hat eben auch schon auch einen Zwang, sich selbst zu publizieren, nicht unbedingt herauszustellen, aber einfach auch sichtbar zu sein, weil das eben in unserer gesellschaftlichen Kommunikation jetzt auch dazu gehört.
Weil das sowieso menschlich ist. Niemand versteht das besser als ein Schriftsteller. Ich meine, wir sind ja sowieso die größten Exhibitionisten, wenn wir in unsere Bücher irgendwie alles reinschreiben, was wir denken und fühlen, gewissermaßen. Also dieses Bedürfnis ist legitim und natürlich.
Nur übertroffen von Radiomoderatoren.
Die ja auch immer nackt da sitzen. Auch du ja jetzt. Völlig unbekleidet, weil du sozusagen deinen akustischen Exhibitionismus ausleben musst.
Die Hörer, die wollen alle Kameras.
Aber Tim, ich bin nicht sicher, ob die Leute sich wirklich bewusst machen, was sie da tun. Das merkt man ja immer wieder bei diesen Fällen, die er dann inzwischen geradezu hysterisch verhandelt werden in der traditionellen Presse, was ein Beispiel ist für wie gefährlich das Internet ist. Diese Fälle, wo irgendjemand dann quasi verleumdet wird, weil irgendetwas über ihn bekannt geworden ist. Und weil dann auf YouTube oder sonst irgendwo die Information weltweit plötzlich zu sehen ist. Wenn man sich anguckt, wie ist diese Information überhaupt ins Netz gekommen, dann ist es ja ganz häufig so, dass die betreffende Person sie selber ins Netz gestellt hat. Und das ist glaube ich wirklich was, obwohl so viele Leute das benutzen. Das machen sich viele Leute nicht klar. Sie machen sich nicht klar, dass es so ist, als würden sie sich nackt ausziehen, sich ins Fenster oder hinter dem Fenster ihrer Wohnung setzen, Licht anmachen und wirklich Tag ein Tag aus sich von einem begaffen lassen.
Aber da bin ich ja völlig unbesorgt, weil ich glaube, das lernen die. Das ist einfach der Umgang mit einem neuen Spielzeug. Dieses Spielzeug wird jetzt erprobt und erforscht. Also wir sind auch schon bei infantilen Metaphern mit Kindern oder so, aber so ähnlich. Und dann merkst du auf einmal, wenn ich hier drücke, das tut weh. Und dann lässt du es vielleicht in Zukunft. Also ich glaube, da erleben wir einfach so, wie Leute langsam den Umgang mit einer echt neuen Geschichte da. Da braucht man gar nichts machen.
Da muss jetzt einfach ein bisschen Schmerz ausgelebt werden, aber da bin ich auch...
Das reguliert sich von selber und mir wäre es eigentlich auch lieber, man würde sich da jetzt gar nicht mit Gesetzen drauf stürzen und sagen, wir müssen verhindern, dass da Leute verleumdet werden. Auf jedem Schulhof werden Leute verleumdet. Das reguliert sich so.
Ja, auf jedem Stammtisch. Die Leute, die jetzt sagen im Spiegelstil, weil es gerade einfällt, weil mich das so schockiert hat, was für Schund im Internet steht...
Der neue Spiegeltitel diese Woche.
Das sind scheinbar Leute, die niemals in der Kneipe waren. Wenn man sich an irgendwo einen Stammtisch hinsetzt, was da geredet wird, ich meine, das ist genauso schlimm wie...
Also den Internet vorzuwerfen, dass da Schund drin ist, das ist ja echt ein faschistischer Vorwurf.
Wo leben die Leute? Offensichtlich gehen sie nie aus der Haustür raus, das ist dann eben so ein Schnösel in Hamburg, so ein ganz feiner Herr, der nur ins Theater geht und offensichtlich nie.
Aber vom Thema abgekommen, also Tim, lasst dich nicht überzeugen, dass wir quasi sagen, man muss bei den Leuten das natürliche Gefühl für ihre Würde wiederbeleben. Du sagst, das funktioniert nicht, weil... Oder zumindest machst du das jetzt sozusagen als Advokatus Diabolis. Du sagst, du bist der Sturebürger, der will es nicht sehen.
Ja, ich versuche mich da halt ein bisschen reinzudenken, weil ich meine, das ist ja eigentlich das, worüber wir reden. Wie kriegt man einfach eine aufgeklärte Diskussion wieder zurück in die Gesellschaft? Und das ist ja auch das, was jetzt im Rahmen der Bundestagswahl von einzelnen Gruppen unternommen wird. Heute auf der PK hast du irgendwie den Namen nicht genannt, aber du hast wahrscheinlich die Piratenpartei gemeint. Also du sagtest, es gibt dann auch mal welche, die das auch mal explizit thematisieren. Das wäre ja mal was Neues. Und es ist ja auch die große Fragestellung, dass jetzt die Eigenwahrnehmung der Netzbürger sozusagen übertrieben gibt es tatsächlich eine Bewegung oder nicht. Aber letzten Endes will ich es jetzt nicht zu breit streuen und mich schon noch mal ein bisschen darauf festbeißen, wo wir bisher hergekommen sind mit der Angst, die offensichtlich da ist. Die Leute sind irgendwie verunsichert, so kaufen halt irgendwie alles ein. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie kann man den Wert der Freiheit an dieser Stelle wirklich deutlich machen? Geht das nur über Würde?
Das ist das eine. Also ich glaube schon, dass das wichtig ist, das den Leuten zurückzugeben, weil wir halt einfach auch jetzt schon Gott sei Dank recht lange in der Gesellschaft wohnen. Ich rede jetzt nicht für die ehemalige DDR, sondern vielleicht mehr für die Bundesrepublik oder so, wo die Würde des Einzelnen ja auch tatsächlich gehätschelt und gepempert wird. Wir erleben nicht viele erniedrigende Erfahrungen, die woanders zum Alltag gehören. Und das ist ja leider oft so, dass wenn einem nichts wehtut, vergisst man auch, dass da eigentlich was ist. Und das ist glaube ich schon ein guter Weg oder ein wichtiger Weg, den Leuten wieder klar zu machen, ihr müsst stolzer sein, ihr dürft euch nicht selbst erniedrigen, ihr müsst ein Gefühl für eure Würde haben, auch dann, wenn man nicht sieht, dass euch jemand aussperrt. Und wenn ihr nicht schon im Kerker auf der Strommatte sitzt, dann ihr müsst euch dessen bewusst sein. Damit einher gehört auch der Aufruf, den ich wirklich für wichtig halte, den Leuten klar zu machen, lasst euch nicht ins Boxhorn jagen. Also wenn ihr euch innerlich verunsichert fühlt, aufgrund von, was wir hier schon jetzt angesprochen haben, keine Solidarität oder so, tragisch genug. Aber wenn euch jetzt in den Medien Tag für Tag und von der Politik als Verkaufsargument immer wieder das nächste Untergangsszenario vorgehalten wird, wenn ihr da wirklich systematisch mit Bedrohungen umstellt werdet, distanziert euch davon. Also schaltet den Verstand ein, macht euch klar, dass diese Bedrohungen nicht real sind. Und wir versuchen in dem Buch halt eben auch mit einem relativen Rechercheaufwand nachzuweisen, wo man diese Bedrohungen überhaupt tatsächlich faktisch nachweisen kann, wo sie denn sind und wo nicht. Um den Leuten klar zu machen, dass dieses Weltbild, was ja so einsickert, dass wir tatsächlich kurz vor, ich weiß nicht kurz vor, was stehen wir denn, kurz vor dem Untergang des westlichen christlichen Abendlandes oder so, also whatever, dass das eine Fiktion ist. Auf jeden Fall ist das christlich. Genau. Und dass es auch peinlich ist, so ein Angsthase zu sein. Dass Angst eigentlich auch nichts ist, worauf man stolz sein soll.
Dazu möchte ich nur sagen, dass es eigentlich auch das Wesen der aufklärischen Schrift seit jeher war, dass sie den Leser zum Nachdenken anregt, dass sie versucht, in ihm einen Wandel in seine Wahrnehmung herbeizuführen, dass es aber niemals eine Handlungsanordnung war. Wenn ich an die großartigen Pamphlete des 18. Jahrhunderts denke, dann ist das immer das Ziel, dass man sagt, Leute, ihr könnt die Realität anders sehen. Aber ich kann mich an überhaupt keinen Pamphlet erinnern, wo dann steht, übrigens, jetzt müsst ihr rausgehen und die Partei wählen und übrigens 1., 2., 3., 4. sind eure potenziellen Schritte.
Man würde sich selbst widersprechen. Du kannst ja den Leuten nicht erst sagen, selber denken und dann sagen, was sie tun sollen. Deswegen verstehe ich sowieso nicht, warum uns heute den ganzen Tag alle fragen, ja, und wie wehrt man sich denn jetzt dagegen? Also anstatt halt erstmal zu sagen, Leute, es geht darum, in dem Köpfen was zu kapieren, wie ihr euch dann wärt, das könnt ihr dann ja bitteschön auch mal selber entscheiden. Jetzt fragt doch nicht uns, die wir gerade irgendwie für freiheitliches Denken votieren. Da ist so ein Widerspruch in diesem Vorder nach Handlungsanweisungen.
Ja, vielleicht liegt eben das selbstständige Denken auch nicht unbedingt jedem.
Nee, natürlich nicht, aber es sollte doch weiterhin, finde ich, sehr stark Ziel sein, daran zu arbeiten, dass es möglichst viel mehr erfüllt wird.
Ja klar, aber wir haben es ja mit einer Mehrheit zu tun, die das Problem ist. Die Mehrheit sagt, auch ja, Sicherheit, das klingt super, und Freiheit haben wir ja genug, und bzw. empfinden auch diese Gesetzgebung, die wir so kritisieren, nicht unbedingt als Verlust an Freiheit. Ich meine, Vorratsdatenspeicherung, welche Freiheit geht denn da verloren?
Na, es ist eben immer dann schon ein Freiheitsverlust, wenn dir jemand über die Schulter guckt. Aber dieses, also wenn du beobachtet wirst, fängst du an, dein Verhalten zu ändern. Das ist einfach so, das weiß jeder. Ilija hat, glaube ich, diesen Wunder von mir, das ist wirklich sehr treffend empfunden, einen Satz formuliert, der im Buch auch drin steht. Haben sie schon mal versucht, sich vor einer Kamera ganz natürlich zu verhalten? Also Beobachtung ist Einfluss, und wenn wir jetzt ganz freakig werden wollen, können wir ja sogar sagen, dass das ein physikalisches Gesetz ist. Also seit wir die Quantentheorie haben, meinen wir ja sogar zu wissen, soweit man irgendwas wissen kann in der Physik, dass Beobachtung tatsächlich Realität auch im physikalischen Bereich beeinflusst. Also Beobachtung ist eine Handlung, das ist schon bereits der Eingriff, und man muss nicht danach fragen, was denn daraus folgt, um dann die Freiheit einzuschränken. Sie liegt schon darin. Du sagst jetzt weiterhin, okay, das überzeugt die Leute aber nicht. Dann können wir vielleicht noch...
Finanzamt, das überzeugt sie immer.
Wenn sie dann eben doch was zu verbergen haben.
Die Leute, die auch im Zug fahren, habe ich jetzt ein paar Mal Leute überhört, die sich unglaublich darüber aufgeregt haben, dass das BND da in Lichtenstein einfach irgendwelche Sachen ausspioniert hat. Und immer wieder höre ich Leute, die sagen, es ist unglaublich, was das Finanzamt darf. Unfassbar. Wie kommen sie darauf? Also vorhin im Taxi, als ich meine Mutter informierte, war dieser sozusagen Zwanganruf.
Dass du heute Abend im Fernsehen bist, ja?
Da hat sie ja dann gesagt, ich habe eine Frage. Sie hat eine neue Wohnung gekauft, die alte verkauft. Das Finanzamt war ein Brief. Woher hat sie das Geld? Die muss sozusagen... Das heißt, erste Frage, woher weiß das Finanzamt schon, dass sie die Wohnung gekauft hat. Gut, wahrscheinlich wird irgendwie der Grundbuch einen Tag und so weiter weitergeleitet. Aber zweitens, das sind so Sachen, wo die meisten Leute, die sozusagen diese Mehrheit, von der du sagst, dass sie nicht unbedingt selber denken will, wo die meisten Leute sagen, das ist ja eine Schweinerei, was das Finanzamt alles darf.
Ja, wenn sie sonst auf nichts hören wollen, muss man ihnen quasi beweisen, dass sie betroffen sind, ganz konkret. Entweder indem man sagt, Leute, das ist mit dem Schwarzarbeiter, den ihr in Wahrheit hinterm Haus habt. Was ist, wenn Euro-Banknoten tatsächlich mit AirFit-Chips ausgestattet werden und man tatsächlich auf diesem 20-Euro-Schein sehen kann, ihr habt den Amazon-Zuvielten diesem Schwarzarbeiter gegeben. Und man kann das nachweisen. Glaubt ihr dann immer noch, dass ihr nichts zu verbergen habt? Also indem man ihnen klarmacht, nobody is perfect und es kann einfach nicht sein, dass wir auf eine Gesellschaft zusteuern, die jedes kleine und so weiter Vergehen halt auf die Weise offenlegt. Oder man versucht es mit diesen Fällen, die eben zeigen, dass es den Falschen erwischen kann. Also dass diese Idee, es betrifft ja nur Terroristen, weil das steht ja immer dahinter. Also es gibt ja sozusagen Leute, die sagen, ich hab nichts zu verbergen, ziehen ja so eine mythische Grenze. Es gibt Terroristen. Und man weiß auch quasi immer, wer die sind. Also das sind keine Verdächtigen mit Unschuldsvermutung, sondern das sind Terroristen, als apodiktisch feststehender Begriff. Und dann gibt es Bürger. Und Anti-Terror-Gesetze sind ja nur für Terroristen und nicht für Bürger. Und deswegen haben die das Gefühl, sie sind nicht gemeint. Also muss man ihnen quasi irgendwie erklären oder vorführen, das ist auch ein Kapitel in diesem Buch, dass diese Grenze zwischen Terrorist und Bürger eine fiktive ist. Es ist sowieso schon mal eine politisch äußerst bedenkliche, weil es nichts anderes ist als eine neue Form von Rassismus, die da im Grunde gepflegt wird. Oder zumindest eine andere Form von, also eine Selektionstechnik ist das. Aber wenn sie darauf immer noch nicht hören wollen, dann muss man ihnen quasi zeigen, das trifft eben auch Leute, die überhaupt gar nichts gemacht haben. Und dann freuen wir uns halt über einige Beispielsfälle, die man da bringen kann.
Aus der Sicht des Staates ist jeder Bürger ein potenzieller Terrorist.
Da würden halt der von Tim vorgeführte wirklich sturköpfige, häusgewege Leser natürlich sagen, wieso beweist es? Aber dann kann man ihm wenigstens sagen, guck mal, hier haben wir eine Handvoll von Fällen, wo genau das passiert ist, da sind Leute eingesperrt worden, weil sie den falschen Begriff in ihrer Doktorarbeit verwendet haben.
Ja, und in Deutschland erst eine Handvoll von Fällen, aber in England, USA, ich meine die Guantanamo-Fälle, also das ist mittels des Schütterns, das ich kenne, einige dieser Fälle von Leuten, die wirklich, also einer war sogar minderjährig, 15 Jahre alt oder so, irgendwo aufgegriffen, Fehler, und der lag jetzt, wie viele Jahre jetzt, sieben Jahre? In Isolationshaft. Also sieben Jahre in Isolationshaft ist, das wird übrigens auch selten genug gesagt, Isolationshaft ist die völlige Zerstörung eines Menschen, und zwar schon nach drei Jahren. Also mein Onkel war in den bulgarischen Gefängnissen insgesamt fünf Jahre in Isolationshaft, und ich habe da sehr viel gehört darüber, wie es ist, und einiges gelesen. Also Isolationshaft selbst, wenn es kurz dauert, wenn man ein eher mental schwacher Mensch ist, ist absolut tödlich. Also es ist sozusagen so, wie man wird als Mensch ausgelöscht. Insofern sind das nicht jetzt irgendwelche kleinen Fälle, sondern das sind wirklich schon Dutzende von Menschen eigentlich fertig gemacht worden, kaputt gemacht worden.
Jetzt werden ja aber auch verschiedene Fälle, worauf du dich eben gerade bezogen hast mit der Diplomarbeit, das war wahrscheinlich der Fall von dem Andre Holm, dem wir irgendwie alle dankbar sind.
Eigentlich müsste man dir mal eine Postkarte schreiben und sagen, ok, du hast drunter gelitten, aber wir freuen uns echt, dass dir das passiert ist.
Weil es sozusagen ein exemplarischer Fall ist.
Genau, um einfach mal sagen zu können, guck mal, so was passiert ja ständig. Der Witz ist nur, du erfährst es nicht. Es gibt noch ein paar mehr, aber die meisten wirst du nicht erfahren. Was ich aus meiner Zeit bei der Staatsanwaltschaft weiß, ist, da reden wir jetzt auch noch vor, 11. September usw. Generell gilt, man muss ja eigentlich, wenn man abhört oder bespitzelt, und der Verdacht bestätigt sich nicht, nach einer bestimmten Zeit den Betroffenen davon informieren. Das wird aber nie gemacht, nie. Die Begründung dafür ist immer, weil da gibt es eine entsprechende Klausel in den Gesetzen, dass der Verdacht eben noch nicht endgültig ausgeräumt war. Und deswegen kann man, um nicht zukünftige Ermittlungen zu gefährden, den Betroffenen nicht in Kenntnis setzen. Weil, falls er doch ein schlimmer Finger ist, weiß er ja dann, dass er beobachtet wird. Ich meine, wer nicht ganz doof ist, weiß er das sowieso. Aber das ist die Argumentation, die Logik des Gesetzes. Deswegen muss man ihn doch nicht informieren. Was dazu führt, dass nie irgendjemand davon informiert wird, dass er abgehört wurde. Was auch dazu führt, dass es gesellschaftlich überhaupt keine Statistiken gibt, keine Evidenz, wie viele Leute tatsächlich, obwohl sie nie irgendetwas gemacht haben, in den Fokus von solchen Maßnahmen fallen. Das ist halt ein Argumentationsproblem für Leute wie uns, die darauf hinweisen wollen, dass es gefährlich ist, was da passiert.
Aber es wird ja auch immer auf erfolgreiche Terrorfahndungen hingewiesen, auch in den letzten Jahren. Man kann jetzt sagen, es gibt ja keinen Terror in Deutschland. Da gibt es dann gleich das Gegenargument mit den Aviso, wir haben sie doch hier festgenommen. Genau, die Sauerlandgruppe, die da fleißig am Bomben basteln war. Dann gab es diesen nicht explodierten Sprengsatz im Zug. In Köln war das, genau.
Das ist grandios, wirklich.
Was ist da mit?
In acht Jahren zwei Fälle.
Ja, aber habt ihr euch mit den Fällen ein bisschen auseinandergesetzt, was so da abgegangen ist?
Ja, ich glaube, Kofferbomber kann man ja ganz schnell klären. Das ist ja einfach ein technischer Fehler. Das ist halt nicht explodiert. Das heißt, da hat man gar nichts verhindert, sondern man hat der Glück.
Ja, aber die Bedrohung gab es sozusagen.
Ja klar, aber die Bedrohung gab es ja als sozusagen nicht erfolgte Gefahr. Wie nennt man das?
Also Ilija will sagen, die wurde nicht verhindert durch irgendwelche Antiterrogesetze.
Wie war dieser Begriff mit... Ach, ist egal, ich hab jetzt einen Aussetzer. Auf jeden Fall, und die Leute wurden ja gefasst, auch nicht aufgrund irgendwelcher neuen Geschichten, weder Vorratsdatenspeicherung, oder auch nur Videoüberwachung.
Videoüberwachung wurde aber groß gefeiert in dem Kontext.
Ja, aber das stimmt nicht. Das ist eine Lüge. Das ist eine Lüge oder zumindest eine Verzerrung.
Also es hat überhaupt nicht dazu geführt, dass sie gefasst wurden. Die wurden verpfiffen.
Ich habe mich in dem Fall nicht so genau angeschaut, aber dieses Videomaterial hat meiner Meinung nach vor allem dazu geführt, dass das Fernsehen was zu zeigen hatte.
Genau, aber da war ja nicht viel drauf zu sehen.
Da fuhr jemand eine Rolltreppe hoch.
Ja, aber da war ja nichts zu erkennen. Das hat die Polizei ja sogar selber dann zugegeben. Also das ist ja sowieso nicht die Polizei, die sowas erfindet.
Konnten Sie denn überhaupt sicher sagen, dass dieser im Fernsehen gezeigte Clip tatsächlich diese Person war?
Das weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, da kümmert sich auch inzwischen keine Sau mehr drum. Aber was Fakt ist, das sagt die Polizei selber, er wurde nicht gefasst aufgrund dieser Videoaufnahmen.
Also er wurde gefasst, weil der eine ja libanesischer Herkunft ist und weil der libanesische Geheimdienst ihn schon länger irgendwie im Blick hatte und der die libanesische Geheimdienst hat einen Tipp gegeben an die deutschen Kollegen, dann haben sie ihn gefasst.
Und dadurch über den einen dann auch den anderen. Also das war wirklich klassische Ermittlungsmethode, wie sie ja 5000 Millionen Jahren irgendwie durchgeführt wird.
Das ist eine Art der Schastra im alten indischen Lehrbuch.
Und bei den Sauerländern?
Ja, sehr ähnlich. Naja, bei den Sauerländern muss man sagen, dass unsere Informationen sich beziehen auf eine wirklich grandiose Reportage, die man als Podcast noch finden kann. Deutschlandradio, der Redakteur hieß oder der Journalist hieß Walter von Rossum. Der hat also 45 Minuten lang das Ganze aufgeschlüsselt. Das ist eine ganz merkwürdige Frage. Zum einen muss man sagen, dass die ja seit längerem unter Beobachtung standen. Und zwar nicht nur von zwei oder drei Polizisten, sondern ich hab die Zahlen jetzt vergessen, also ganze Einheiten.
Es ist einfach absurd. Also wenn wir das glauben, dann war ja quasi der gesamte Ort, in dem das stattfand, also wo die diese Bomben gebaut haben, der bestand ja quasi nur noch aus Ermittlern. Beziehungsweise war es allen Beteiligten absolut bekannt, dass hier seit Monaten Polizisten unterwegs sind, die ständig auch dann Nachbarn fragen und irgendwie ein Haus mieten, wo sie ihre ganze Technik, ihre Überwachungstechnik reinräumen und dann immer anreisen. Wenn Schichtwechsel ist, dann weiß der wieder nicht genau, welches Haus das war. Dann fragt er, also mit einer absurden Unprofessionalität und Offenheit wurde das durchgeführt, also in einer Art und Weise, dass man sich fragt, ob das überhaupt Wahnsinn ist.
Das Zweite, was man sagen muss, ist, dass sie den...
Wo man sich fragt, was machen die da jahrelang, ja? Verhindern die jetzt gerade einen Terroranschlag? Oder freuen die sich darüber, dass sie endlich mal was zu tun haben? Oder warum werden da jahrelang diese Leute beurteilt?
Ja, die freuen sich, dass wir endlich mal vier einheimische Terroristen haben. Das ist wie ein Sexer im Lotto. Endlich haben wir mal welche. Jahrelang gesucht. Und dann dieses Zeugs, ich bin ja ganz schlecht in Chemie, also dieses Zeugs, mit dem man dann Bomben basteln kann, das wurde ihnen ja von V-Männern verkauft. Das heißt, auch das ist schon extrem suspekt. Alles wurde ihnen, nicht nur die chemische Substanz, auch die Zünder wurden angeblich von Geheimdienstmitarbeitern verkauft.
Das ist so ähnlich wie beim NPD-Verbot. Du versuchst eine Partei zu verbieten, dann stellst du fest, die besteht nur aus V-Leuten. So hat man das Gefühl, man verhaftet ein paar Terroristen und in Wahrheit besteht der ganze Fall im Wesentlichen aus V-Leuten. Das aufzudecken zeigt im Grunde nur...
Was ganz schlimm ist, dass der Kopf, der sie angestachelt hat, ein Türke ist, der ein berühmter oder berüchtigter Agent ist für den türkischen Geheimdienst und der da eine ganz dubiose Rolle spielt. Was dann noch dazukommt, ist, dass diese Leute von einer Naivität sind, von einer kindlichen Unbesorgtheit, die überhaupt nichts mit konspirativer Arbeit zu tun hat. Die haben ja, das fand ich das Absurdeste überhaupt in dem ganzen Fall, die haben ja Interviews gegeben. Die haben tatsächlich, ich glaube Stern war es so, die haben einem Stern Interviews gegeben, wenn die noch Bomben passen.
Die haben lauter so Sachen gemacht, wo man eigentlich das Gefühl hatte, die schreien nur, hallo, hier sind wir und wir bauen eine Bombe. Also da war nichts konspirativ. Was man an dem Fall vor allem eigentlich sehen kann, finde ich, wenn man da nüchtern drauf guckt, ist, dass eben diese Horror- und Bedrohungsszenarien, die uns immer vorgehalten werden, werden gerade nicht stimmen. Weil Fakt ist, da waren jetzt halt diese drei Jungs, die haben diese Bomben gebaut. Das ist unerfreulich. Aber faktisch gab es nicht die geringste Bedrohung, weil von Anfang an keine dieser Bomben auch nur echt war. Die haben mit Zeug rumgespielt, was ihnen irgendwelche V-Leute zur Verfügung gestellt haben.
Ob das gar nicht hätte funktionieren können?
Und die sind auch nicht Teil der Al-Kaida. Die sind noch nicht mal Teil irgendeiner groß angelegten Terrororganisation. Die sind zu dritt. Das sind diese drei Typen. Und die sind dumm wie Bohnen. Also offensichtlich. Ein Trauerspiel.
Wir haben noch nicht die richtigen Terroristen in Deutschland.
Ja, aber hurra. Und dann liest man aber trotzdem jetzt wieder kurz vor der Wahl, dass uns halt die Massengeiselnamen drohen und dass all das bevorsteht. Und das steht wirklich in keinem Verhältnis zu dem, was da dann tatsächlich...
Massengeiselnamen gibt es jetzt auch? Davon habe ich noch nichts gehört.
Echt nicht? Du bist nicht informiert.
Ilija hat dann jede Menge Flyer vorbereitet.
Ja, Volker Bouffier. Ich hab dir gesagt, der hessische Innenminister, ganz wichtiger Job, das ist dort, wo die blödsten Sprüche in Deutschland produziert werden. Und der tritt vor die Presse und sagt, er kennt sich aus.
Er hat ja Zugang zum islamistischen Potenzial.
Genau, seine Geheimdienste arbeiten Tag und Nacht. Und deswegen kann er jetzt sagen, O-Ton, es gibt eindeutige Erkenntnisse, dass Al-Kaida massiv Schaden anrichten will.
Das ist doch schon mal eine Hammererkenntnis.
Entschuldige mal, das finanzieren wir mit unseren Steuergeldern, dass der BND jetzt ganz klar sagen kann, Al-Kaida will Schaden anrichten. Und du grinst, anstatt jetzt beeindruckt zu sein und dankbar. Und dann sagt er, deshalb gilt auch hier nichts ausschließen, auf alles vorbereitet sein. Was schon ziemlich faschistisch ist, wenn man da ein bisschen drüber nachdenkt, dass dieser Satz alles beinhaltet. Aber im Konkreten sagt er, dass sie die Bundestagswahlen beeinflussen wollen, weil Afghanistan einsetzt in Afghanistan. Und dass sie, wir wissen nicht, wann und wo sie zuschlagen werden. Also cover your ass. Also ich hab doch alles, falls es tatsächlich mal zum Anschlag kommt, sagt der Innenminister.
Ich hab's gewusst.
Ich hab sie gewarnt. Ich hab gesagt, ich weiß, Al-Ka'ida will Böses und irgendwo... Klagen sie zu. Ich hab's ganz genau gesagt und mir kann jetzt keiner einen Vorwurf machen. Und auf jeden Fall diesmal haben sie...
Wenn nichts passiert, war es sozusagen die davon ausgehende Bedrohung, diese Terroristen, die verhindert hat, dass was passiert ist, richtig?
Du, Almelich denkt Tim wie ein Innenminister. Du noch ein paar Stunden und dir wird der Job auch angeboten. Genau und was ich ganz toll finde, er bestätigte, dass die GSG 9 und die Sondereinsatzkommandos bereits für den Fall von Massengeiselnahmen trainieren.
Was ja kein Fehler ist.
Weil man auf alles vorbereitet sein muss. Ist ja klar, es kann alles möglich passieren.
Vorbereitet zu sein, da habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt gar nichts gegen. Geiselnahmen sind ja nun nicht...
Lieber Herr Innenminister von Berlin, ist jetzt eine Massengeiselnahme, kannst du uns das mal erklären.
Und wie bereiten sie sich darauf vor?
Na die rennen irgendwo rein und schreien rum und rennen wieder raus, schätzungsweise, oder?
Na so wie Mozart damals in Entepe, die sind reingegangen und haben auf hebräisch gesagt, alle hinlegen und haben dann nach einer Sekunde geschossen. Und die, die noch standen, waren halt offensichtlich keine, die hebräisch waren. Allerdings gab es dann zwei oder drei Schwerhöhe, die hat es auch erwischt.
Sie hatten auch gleich alle erschießen können, da wäre es auch vorbei gewesen. Hauptsache trainiert. Na gut, man muss nicht ganz zynisch sein. Aber klar, die Frage ist schon, also ich würde schon gerne mal sehen, worauf die sich da genau vorbereiten und was das für ein Szenario ist. Also wir haben darüber spekuliert, dass sie vielleicht das Oktoberfest meinen, dass das Oktoberfest als Geisel genommen werden soll. Das wäre auch eine tolle, symbolische Sache.
Ich meine, dass sich jetzt polizeiliche Einheiten, wie militärisch sie ihr Habitus auch sein mag, sich auf Dinge vorbereiten, technisch auswählen.
Aber du sagst ja selber schon, wie militärisch sie sich immer gerieren. Also lassen wir uns noch mal darauf zurückkommen, was Polizeiarbeit eigentlich auch im Wesentlichen ist.
Ich will ja nur sagen, Geiselnamen hat es gegeben und wird es wahrscheinlich auch immer wieder geben.
Aber in Deutschland ist das jetzt nicht unser vorherrschendes Problem, oder?
Nein, das ist nicht unser Problem.
Also wenn die sich unbedingt auf irgendwas vorbereiten wollen, dann würde einem da ja andere Dinge vielleicht noch eher einfallen, als ausgerichtene Massengeiselnamen.
Also das ist Sonnpropaganda. Also sich darauf vorzubereiten, das ist sinnvoll, weil die passieren zu Beginn und am Ende der Ferien massenhaft, da sterben Tausende von Menschen. Und sich darauf vorzubereiten, das wäre jetzt richtig sinnvoll.
Ja, ich meine, sich auf etwas vorzubereiten, das ist das eine. Die Frage ist ja, was wird damit bezweckt, dass das jetzt so thematisiert wird?
Ja genau, warum steht das hier?
Und dann sagt er, sehr gut, das ist nämlich genau das, wofür das Ganze dient. Daher sprach er sich erneut für einen Einsatz der Bundeswehr im Inneren Haus. Darum geht es nämlich. Es müsste klare Regeln für gemeinsame Einsätze von Polizei und Militär geben. Zitat, das ist jetzt wieder so ein wunderbarer Satz eines typischen hessischen Innenministers. Bei Gefahr im Verzug muss es möglich sein, dass es direkten Funkkontakt der Einsatzleitung zum Piloten eines Abfangjägers gibt und man sich nicht mit Händewinken verständigen muss. Das ist doch super. Das ist wie, wer sagte, man muss sich das Internet, ich drucke mir das Internet aus?
Alle.
Soll das Scheufe? Auf jeden Fall, das sind einfach so klassische Sätze. Wir wollen nicht, dass die Einsatzleitung und der Pilot des Abfangjägers sich mit Händewinken verständigen.
Bosbach sagte, Online-Durchsuchung geht nicht mit Messer und Gabel. Das finde ich vergleichbar kompetent.
Also da wird einem schon Angst umbangen, wenn das die Innenminister sind.
In ein paar Wochen, um genau zu sein, in einem Monat wird es ja hier eine Demonstration geben in Berlin. 12.9. Genau. Freiheit statt Angst. Das sind jetzt so beides Begriffe, die wir jetzt hier auch schon so ein bisschen gedreht haben, muss auch zugeben. Das war so ein bisschen Teilmotivation, das auch noch mal so ein bisschen zu beleuchten, was eigentlich drinsteckt in so einem Titel. Man sagt Freiheit statt Angst, dann ist das ja dieses, kann man auch vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen anders drehen, wenn wir jetzt eigentlich schon festgestellt haben, so viel Angst unterwegs ist, dass die Leute sich eben bestimmten Argumenten auch nicht mehr so richtig öffnen wollen oder überhaupt erst mal nicht öffnen wollen. Es ist vielleicht sogar auch, dass man Angst hat vor der Freiheit, dass die Leute einfach, dass ihnen einfach Freiheit selber schon eher suspekt vorkommt, so mit dieser ganzen Freiheit weiß der Geier wohin das geht. Ich habe von irgendeinem russischen Dorf bei Moskau gehört, wo Leute sich alle freiwillig unter so einen kleinen Scheinhitler gruppieren und sozusagen als Dorfordnung vollkommen akzeptieren, dass er ihnen den Ton angibt und dass sie einfach so nach seinen Worten leben. Und das ist dann einfach mal so ihr lokaler Diktator und sie sind glücklich. Offensichtlich ist diese ungeteilte Freiheitsliebe nicht überall so.
Es ist ja letztlich auch so, dass wir, also konkret jetzt Ilija und ich, wenn wir halt so zum Beispiel so ein Buch schreiben oder hier über solche Dinge reden, dann wollen wir ja, wie das in Demokratien so üblich ist, unsere Welt sich sozusagen populär machen. Wir wollen das, was wir für gut und richtig halten, möglichst vielen anderen Leuten irgendwie zugänglich zu machen, vielleicht sogar auch Leute überzeugen. Uns erscheint das halt so gut und richtig, dass wir natürlich auch das Gefühl haben, das ist die einzig mögliche rational-logische Betrachtungsweise. Als einigermaßen objektiv denkender Mensch wissen wir natürlich, es gibt die andere mit einer gleichen inneren Schlüssigkeit der Argumentation. Und wer jetzt sozusagen gewinnt in Zukunft, in unserer Gesellschaft, das ist glaube ich einfach noch überhaupt gar nicht raus. Also ich hätte vor fünf, sechs Jahren noch gesagt, es gewinnen auf jeden Fall die anderen. Also wenn wir das jetzt mal so antagonistisch aufmachen, es gewinnen die, die sagen, unsere Gesellschaft muss sicherer werden. Und wenn ich eine Zukunftsvision zeichnen soll, wie es in 30 Jahren bei uns ist, dann würde ich sagen, nimm Großbritannien heute, multipliziere es mit zehn, das ist unsere Zukunft. Seit ein paar Jahren würde ich sagen, also es ist vielleicht noch kein Unentschieden, aber ganz so sicher bin ich mir jetzt doch nicht mehr. Also vielleicht ändert sich da doch noch mal was.
Und was hat den Wandel in den Gedanken verursacht?
Na, was du vorhin auch schon so angedeutet hast, so was, wie hast du es genannt, Netzbürgerbewegung oder so. Also dass sich, aber es ist auch nicht nur Netz, also nehmen wir es als Schlag. Dass sich seit ein paar Jahren zum Beispiel auf einmal anfangen, Föhtons von irgendwelchen Zeitungen für das Thema zu interessieren, die vorher hermetisch verriegelt waren gegenüber so einer Denkweise. Also die haben sich sowieso gar nicht damit befasst, also mit Antiterrorkampf, aber wenn, dann nur Affirmativ, also es gab keine Kritik an diesem Vorgehen. Das hat sich ein bisschen gedreht, vielleicht auch durch den zeitlichen Abstand zum 11. September, der so ein Tabu war. Also du konntest Jahre nach dem 11. September ja nichts gegen Antiterrorkampf sagen, weil dann alle sofort aufschrien und die armen 4000 Toten und diese Katastrophe und dieses unfassbare Elend und so. Und das kannst du doch jetzt hier nicht legitimieren wollen, du Islam-Versteher oder so. Also das ging eine Zeit lang nicht. Inzwischen geht das eben dann doch schon wieder so ein bisschen. Plus so ein paar andere Sachen. Online-Petitionen, die Gründung der Piratenpartei, das ist jetzt alles wirklich noch sehr klein und das sind Anfänge. Aber alles fängt ja mal irgendwie klein an.
Aber dir macht das Mut sozusagen.
Ein bisschen schon, ja. Also ich bin jetzt optimistischer als ich vor drei, vier Jahren war. Absolut.
Also es gibt ja jetzt konkret zwei Sachen, an denen man es vielleicht ein bisschen abmessen kann. Also eins der Sachen im Vorfeld waren, war ein Essay, den ich geschrieben habe mit dem Titel Mit Sicherheit in den Untergang und der wurde unter anderem auch von einer österreichischen Zeitung gedruckt und ins Internet gestellt und die haben mir dann gesagt, dass sie noch niemals auf einen Artikel so viele Reaktionen dann im Netz hatten. Es waren wirklich, ich habe es nicht gezählt, ich glaube es waren so 200 oder so, es waren wirklich sehr viele und die meisten haben gesagt...
Wie hieß der Artikel?
Mit Sicherheit in den Untergang. Aber alles, was im Artikel steht, steht auch in unserem Buch, den muss man nicht suchen. Ich bringe es nur deswegen an, weil das für mich auch ermutigend war zu sehen, dass ganz viele Menschen sagen, sehr gut, wir müssen uns dagegen wehren, auch wir denken das, endlich wird es mal gesagt. Ganz häufig kam der Argument, endlich lese ich das mal in der Presse. Die Leute haben das richtig vermisst.
Endlich sagt es mal jemand.
Und das zweite, was heute der Redakteur von der Zeit gesagt hat, wo ja letzte Woche ein Abdruck von unserem Buch war, er hat gesagt, dass sehr, sehr viele Reaktionen auf den Vorabdruck kamen und die meisten auch in diesem Sinne sehr, sehr positiv. Also und auch er hat den Eindruck als Journalist, dass es allmählich eine Bewegung ist, dass ein bisschen sich der Geist ändert.
Ja, der Artikel wurde, also der Artikel, wenn ich es richtig sage, war das die Einleitung zu eurem Buch, ne? Ja, ja, das wurde auch auf Twitter fleißig rumgereicht. Das war offensichtlich. Vielleicht mal so als, also ich bin ja eigentlich auch Optimist, so von Grundsatz, nicht nur weil ich irgendwie keine Versicherung abschließen will, sondern einfach auch, weil ich auch denke, man kann auch immer alles wieder drehen. Und irgendwie ist es ja auch in den Köpfen schwierig, wenn man immer auch nur mit Angst argumentiert. Also gerade in dieser ganzen Debatte mit, warum willst du denn der Sicherheit Vorrang geben über Freiheit und so weiter? Man weiß, diese Leute leben eh schon mit Ängsten. Wenn man dann argumentativ kommt mit, aber bedenke doch mal, was alles passieren kann, wenn du irgendwie das machst. Das heißt, man kontert eigentlich die Angstdiskussion mit einer anderen Angstdiskussion, worauf viele dann vielleicht auch einfach zumachen und sagen, oh Gott, nicht noch mehr Angst. Ich habe eh schon genug. Das auch gar nicht mehr sortiert bekommen und auch nicht so sehen, dass die eine Angst jetzt die andere eigentlich auflösen soll. Dass man dann eigentlich versucht, so eine Art Gegenschein zu schicken, der aber irgendwie einfach nicht angenommen wird, weil die einfach schon komplett zugemacht haben. Warum dreht man das Ganze nicht um und sagt, Mut zur Freiheit? Wir argumentieren jetzt einfach mal positiv, was es doch alles für großartige Vorzüge gibt, wenn man ein freiheitlich organisiertes Gesellschaftssystem hat. Weil ich denke, das verschwindet in dieser ganzen Debatte. Man fühlt sich auch geradezu in die Ecke gedrückt von diesen ganzen Sicherheitsdebatten, die ich eigentlich nur, wir lachen ja eigentlich die ganze Zeit, die ist lächerlich. Die ist so lächerlich, dass es wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht mal so wertvoll ist, unbedingt darauf einzugehen.
Also wir lachen auch aus Trauer, glaube ich. Es gibt so, wenn man sehr lange über etwas sehr Galgenmour.
Ja, das ist auch so ein bisschen das Treifen im Wald.
Ja, also und Zynismus und all das genau.
Ja, aber warum drehen wir es nicht einfach um und sagen, ich meine, wenn ihr das jetzt so hört, was könnt ihr denn sozusagen für die Freiheit alles so ins Feld führen? Ja, wenn man das jetzt mal als Sales-Droid auffasst.
Kostellosen Musik downloaden oder was?
Ja, ich meine jetzt einfach gesagt, ist irgendwie ein System, was auf Vertrauen basiert und so weiter, funktioniert besser als alles, was auf Misstrauen basiert.
Genau, das ist ja genau das, was wir gerade schon hatten. Also das ist im Grunde ja, wir reden vielleicht hier auf einem abstrakten Niveau, aber das sind letztlich ja genau solche Argumente. Wenn du sagst, wenn wir Sicherheit wollen, brauchen wir die Freiheit zuerst, das ist ja ein positives Argument. Also wir wollen niemanden einschüchtern. Wir sagen den Leuten ja gerade, habt keine Angst. Vertraut einfach darauf, dass wenn wir möglichst viel Freiheit haben, dass auch der Weg zur Sicherheit ist. Und wenn ihr es uns nicht glaubt, dann schaut in die Geschichtsbücher oder guckt es euch im Ausland an, vergleicht einfach Staaten miteinander. Schaut euch ein Land an wie den Terrorstaat Island oder halt schaut euch irgendein Land an, wo die Freiheit eigentlich relativ weitgehend verwirklicht ist.
Island ist vielleicht nicht so ein gutes Beispiel.
Na gut, dann schaut euch Deutschland an, wo wir doch gerade eh hier leben. Und dann schaut euch im Vergleich zum Beispiel, was Ilija meinte Saudi Arabien an. Und dann seht ihr sozusagen, was gibt es da für Gesetzgebungen, wie ist die Gesellschaft organisiert, wo ist mehr Kontrolle, wo ist weniger Kontrolle, wo ist die Kriminalität höher und wo ist sie niedriger. Also ihr könnt es wirklich sehen, wenn euch das Vertrauen...
Ist die Kriminalität höher in Saudi Arabien?
Als hier, ja, viel höher.
Weil ich kenne Zahlen nicht.
Genau, aber deswegen versuchen wir mit solchen Beispielen eben, das den Leuten anschaulich zu machen, weil du hast ja gerade sozusagen...
Lässt sich das denn durchgehend behaupten sozusagen, dass es so ein direktes Verhältnis gibt von Freiheit zu Kriminalität?
Wir haben es nicht für 198 Std.
nicht bestellt. Nein, aber ich habe mich sehr damit beschäftigt, als ich versucht habe, Jura zu studieren. In der Kriminalologie gibt es sehr viele Untersuchungen, die immer wieder beweisen, dass es überhaupt keinen krasalen Zusammenhang gibt zwischen Straftrohung und abnehmender oder zunehmender Kriminalität. Es gibt sehr viele Beispiele, wo sie danach zunimmt. Es gibt andere Beispiele, wo sie abnimmt. Die Vermutung der Chimnologen ist, dass es eher andere Faktoren hat. Ein gutes Beispiel aus den letzten Jahren ist ja in den USA dieses fatale Gesetz der Three Strikes. Also egal, was das für eine Vorurteilung ist, bei der dritten Vorurteilung kriegt man lebenslängig. Das hat überhaupt nicht gewirkt. Deswegen ist es jetzt sehr kritisch angesehen in den USA. Das hat überhaupt keinen Erfolg gebracht. Im Gegenteil, die amerikanischen Gefängnisse quellen ja über. Es ist ein massives Problem. Die haben eineinhalb Millionen Häftlinge. Und die Häftlinge, letzte Woche gab es eine Revolte irgendwo in Kalifornien, glaube ich. Die Häftlinge leben ja überwiegend in völlig inhumanen Zuständen. Also das hat man immer wieder versucht. Das ist, glaube ich, erwiesen, dass das kein grundsätzliches Erfolgsrezept ist.
Also wir haben es jetzt trotzdem nicht an 198 quasi durchexzertiert.
Aber es ist, glaube ich, immer wieder bewiesen worden, dass Strafandrohungen, das kennt ja auch jeder von uns aus dem eigenen Leben, also wie viele Sachen haben wir gemacht, obwohl es eine Strafandrohung gibt. Eine Sache, die ich sehr interessant fand, als ich letzte Woche in London war, dass die extrem konservative Financial Times eine Aufmachergeschichte hatte, wo sie sagen, Drogen müssen legalisiert werden. Was mich völlig geschockt hat, also Financial Times, wo sie dann sagen, und die machen ja immer so ganz auf nüchtern, ganz sozusagen nicht emotional, ganz rational, wo sie zig Untersuchungen anführen, dass inzwischen, jenseits von jeglichen Zweifel, ganz klar erwiesen ist, dass Strafgesetze gegen Drogen nur zu höheren Kriminalität führen, zur Schaffung von organisierter Kriminalität und natürlich zu ganz vielen, wie sie es nennen, Sicherheitsproblemen. In dem Artikel wurde sogar etwas gesagt, was ich niemals in einem konservativen Artikel erwartet hätte, dass ein Teil des Afghanistan-Problems eigentlich ein Drogenproblem ist und dass das Drogenproblem zugenommen hat. Das heißt, unser Einsatz dort, um Frieden und Freiheit zu bringen, hat eigentlich vor allem dazu geführt, dass die Drogenmafia wieder besser wirtschaften kann und das insofern auch das weltweite Drogenproblem zunimmt. Das heißt, es gibt manchmal richtige so Umdenk-Situationen, weil einfach die Fakten dermaßen erschlagend in eine Richtung weisen, dass selbst Leute mit gewissen ideologischen Ausrichtungen einfach innehalten müssen und sagen müssen, was tun wir hier überhaupt?
Ja, Mensch, ihr beiden. Jetzt haben wir es aber ganz gut durchgekaut, wa?
Wer jetzt noch nicht überzeugt ist, dem ist auch nichts zu helfen, oder?
Ja, ich habe es jetzt auch nicht so sehr als Überzeugungsgespräch hier geplant und gewertet, auch nicht als Buchvorstellung. Mir ging es so ein bisschen darum, einfach auch so mal so ein bisschen philosophischer einzutauchen und vielleicht auch so die Diskussion so ein bisschen von hinten rum zu befeuern, indem man nicht immer einfach noch mehr Argumente auf den Stapel wirft, sondern auch einfach mal so ein bisschen versucht, sich reinzudenken, was geht denn eigentlich ab so bei uns in der Gesellschaft. Ich denke ja, dass man da einfach auch, habe ich schon gesagt, einfach positiver rangehen muss. Ich denke, man könnte schon mal helfen. Wenn ich mir anschaue, was mich immer so begeistert hat im Leben, dann waren es eigentlich immer Leute, die von irgendetwas begeistert sind. Klar, es gibt dann immer so Divaner und so weiter, aber das sind dann auch manchmal ganz schöne Leute, die ziehen einen irgendwie immer so runter mit allem. Die mögen ja Recht haben und so, aber mir fehlt dann immer so ein bisschen die Vision. Und ich denke so, die Vision dann eben einfach über den Blick sozusagen auszurichten auf das, was eben einfach noch so möglich ist und was das Potenzial einer freiheitlichen Gesellschaft ist, könnte an der Stelle auch ganz gut greifen, oder?
Ja, und ich bin wirklich begeistert von der Freiheit. Also gerade weil ich ein paar Erfahrungen habe, die in eine andere Richtung gehen, es ist oft so, als ich mir denke, es ist einfach wunderbar. Ich rede und schreibe wirklich immer das, was ich will. Ich kann mich an kein einziges Beispiel erinnern, wo ich irgendwie mir überlegt habe, darfst du das sagen? Und gibt es da nicht vielleicht irgendwie Zopf oder Ärger oder irgend so etwas? Und das ist ein sehr, sehr gutes Gefühl. Also ich fühle mich, wenn ich mir jetzt als Autor spreche, sozusagen in meinem Beruf, fühle ich mich einfach sauwohl, weil ich weiß, dass ich in Umständen lebe, wo ich nicht kuschen muss, wo ich mich nicht verbergen muss. Und ich weiß, ich kenne auch Autoren, die überwiegend in den Jahrzehnten vor 1980 im Osten gelebt und geschrieben haben. Ich weiß, wie unendlich erniedrigend das ist und wie sehr diese Leute daran zerbrochen sind. Und insofern ist das einfach ein wunderbares Gefühl. Und ich möchte auf gar keinen Fall das missen, nicht für mich selbst, aber auch für uns alle nicht.
Es hängt halt auch mit einer Glücksvorstellung zusammen. Also es gibt ja angeblich so viele Leute, die Glück als Synonym für materielle Versorgung oder so was sehen. Also die quasi sagen, glücklich bin ich, wenn ich diesen Mercedes habe, den wir vorhin quasi verkauft haben vor der Tür. Das wird immer so behauptet, dass die Leute so denken. Ich bin mir aber wirklich gar nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt stimmt. Also Leute, die sich selber als glücklich definieren oder die, wenn du sie fragst, wie geht es ihr eigentlich, wirklich sagen, oh mir geht es eigentlich super, ich liebe meinen Job oder ich bin total zufrieden mit, wie mein Leben so ist. Und wenn du sie dann fragst, warum, dann sagen sie dir ja nicht, ich bin scheiße reich und ich habe 20 Autos, sondern dann erzählen sie dir eigentlich immer etwas über eine Tätigkeit, über irgendetwas, was sie tun und was ihnen total Spaß macht, was ihnen sinnvoll erscheint. Also du kannst mir blöde Begriffe brauchen, wo sie sich verwirklichen oder wie auch immer. Ist aber egal, wichtig ist, was du auch meintest, sie sind für irgendwas, sie brennen für irgendwas und machen das. Und das heißt, wenn wir überhaupt so alle als Einzelne und auch als Kollektiv darauf raus wollen, dass man irgendwie möglichst glücklich ist, dann glaube ich ja nur dann, wenn wir möglichst vielschichtig plural und breit den Leuten Tätigkeiten erlauben. Egal, ob die im Reden, Machen, Handeln, Erfinden, Chatten oder sonst was bestehen. Und immer, wenn du davon was verbietest und einschränkst, ist das sozusagen wieder eine Glücksmöglichkeit, die da auch verloren geht. Ich glaube, das ist schon ein gutes Argument für Freiheit.
Da fällt mir gerade ein, es gibt ein wunderbares Buch von einer amerikanischen Journalistin, Barbara Ehrenreich, das heißt Nico and Dymed. Das ist die Geschichte, wie sie versucht. Nico and Dymed. Es gibt es auf Deutsch, aber...
Ich verstehe nicht, was das heißt.
Nein, Nickel ist ein Cent. Und Dym ist auch sozusagen ein Wort für eine kleine Münze.
Also so wie Kreuzer und Heller oder Fennich und Cent.
Sie macht daraus Dymed. Also macht sozusagen zum Verb. Also ist ein Wortspiel.
Viel Spaß, die Übersetzer.
Das Spannende an dem Buch ist, sie beschreibt, wie sie versucht, mit einfachen Jobs, die sozusagen für jeden zugänglich sind, über die Runden zu kommen. Und es ist eigentlich eine soziale Geschichte. Aber was mir in Erinnerung geblieben ist, der dritte Job, den sie macht, ist bei diesem riesigen Supermarkt, Walmart. Und eine sehr einprägsame Sache ist, dass sie beschreibt, wie unglücklich dort die Mitarbeiter sind. Nicht so sehr, weil sie einen Hungerlohn kriegen, sondern weil diese Atmosphäre, der Bespitzelung, und keiner weiß, wer hinter seinem Rücken vielleicht, was unglaublich viele Gebote und Verbote gibt dort, keiner weiß, wer unter Umständen ihn denunziert. Diese Atmosphäre macht die Leute ganz fertig. Und sie beschreibt es sehr eindringlich, wie die Leute dort wirklich misstrauisch werden, wie sie grimmig werden, wie sie böse werden. Also es bringt wirklich das Allerböse der Menschen hervor. Das heißt, dieser Kontrollmechanismus in einer einzigen Firma, in einem Supermarkt macht eigentlich die Menschen, die dort länger leben, wirklich fertig.
Sprich, man könnte zusammenfassend sagen, wir wollen eigentlich einen Staat haben, der auf Vertrauen als auf Misstrauen basiert, weil das macht uns unter anderem auch glücklicher.
Genau.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch sicherer.
Und genau. Auch Letzteres funktioniert anders gar nicht. Alles andere sind Chemären. Du kannst nicht sagen, wir sind eine Demokratie, alle Macht geht vom Volke aus. Aber dieses Volk ist dumm und gefährlich und muss deswegen ständig unter Kontrolle gehalten werden. Das ist ein Widerspruch in sich. Also dann muss man auch nicht sagen Demokratie, dann kann man auch gleich alle einzäunen. Also das ist systemlogisch eigentlich, finde ich, ein Erfordernis, den Leuten zu vertrauen. Sonst gibt es keine Rechtfertigung dafür, warum die sich selbst verwalten sollen, wenn das alles so strunzdumme Verbrecher sind.
Na vor allem das Absurde ist, die werden ja dann verwaltet von einigen Repräsentanten des Volkes, die sind ja auch strunzdumm. Das heißt sozusagen einige strunzdumme Gefährliche verwalten die anderen, weil alles strunzdummgefährlich ist.
Kein Wunder, dass man so viele Zäune braucht.
Ja, wie das funktionieren soll.
Okay, Ilija, Juli, ich glaube, wir machen jetzt hier mal einen Punkt.
Genau, wir haben ja auch Hunger.
Wir haben ja auch Hunger, genau, wir haben auch noch ganz andere Bedürfnisse als hier immer nur so reden.
Wir können auch einen Doppelpunkt machen, das passt besser.
Ich fand es trotzdem sehr aufschlussreich. Ja, viel Glück mit eurem Buchprojekt. Und wir sehen uns dann wahrscheinlich hier auch alle auf der Demo, vermute ich mal. Ja, mir fällt jetzt eigentlich nichts weiter ein.
Das ist okay.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
Ja, gerne.
Nur weil die an deinem Schreibtisch sitzen durften.
Genau. Danke für die Bionade und fürs Wasser und...
Genau, und jetzt fahren wir gleich mit meinem dicken, fetten Mercedes hier mit 180 durch die Straßen.
Wieso können wir den Hummer nicht nehmen?
Der Hummer ist verliehen. Okay, ich mache jetzt hier mal Schluss, bevor es noch alberner wird. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Her mit den Kommentaren, wie immer. Block Chaos Radio ccc.de, ihr wisst schon. Und ja, mal gucken. Ich habe hier schon längere Zeit mal eine kleine Pause angekündigt. Es wird immer nichts. Mal sehen, wie es weitergeht. Auf jeden Fall noch viel Spaß bei allem, was ihr tut und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.